ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE BUDGET
SUB-COMMITTEE, UH, NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUB COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A CORPS AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. THIS WILL BE THE FIRST
OF MULTIPLE HEARINGS ON THE
BUDGET OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION OR èC, Dð èC R.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR HOW THE
STATE'S PRISON POPULATION HAS
DECLINED BY NEARLY 25% ROUGHLY
30,000 INDIVIDUALS OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS, WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT'S OVERALL BUDGET HAS
GROWN THE STATE IS FACING A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET PROBLEM THIS
YEAR IN POTENTIAL CUTS THAT
WOULD HARM SOME OF THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS,
SUCH AS FOSTER YOUTH. AS THE NEW
CHAIR OF SUB FIVE. I WANT èC Dð
èC R TO KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING CLOSELY AT THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET AND WE ARE
EXPECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE
A MORE MEANINGFUL CONTRIBUTION
TO SOLVING THE BUDGET PROBLEM TO
ENSURE WE HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYTHING ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
INCLUDING PUBLIC COMMENTS, UH,
WHICH WE WILL TAKE ON ALL ITEMS
AT THE END OF THE HEARING. WE
ARE ASKING PRESENTERS TO KEEP
TESTIMONY UNDER FIVE MINUTES AND
WE WILL BE TIMING YOU UM, I
WOULD ALSO ASK MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS CONCISE.
WOULD ANY MEMBERS LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING BEFORE WE BEGIN? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I WANT TO
MAKE MY COMMENTS NOW, UH,
BECAUSE THEY'RE MORE BROAD IN
GENERAL, UM, IN IN IN NATURE,
AND, UH AND I'LL HAVE TO BE
DIPPING OUT EARLY. SO UM, UH,
THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR I'VE
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE AND WHILE
WE ARE ASKING THEM TO MAKE THEIR
SUBSTANTIAL CUTS, UH, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT FLIES IN THE FACE OF
OUR CUTS IS THAT, UH, WE HAVE
FACILITIES AND, UH, TOOLS
ESSENTIALLY THAT ARE ENTIRELY
INADEQUATE. UH, FOR ATTAINING
THIS IN YOUR MODEL. UH THAT, UH,
WE'VE BEEN, UH, WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT AND THAT CALIFORNIA
MODEL RE RESOLVES AROUND
REVOLVES AROUND, UM, THE HUMANE
TREATMENT AND ALSO, UH, THE, UM,
RE EDUCATION AND GETTING PEOPLE
PREPARED TO GET BACK OUT, UH,
ONCE THEY ARE AND BE GOOD
NEIGHBORS. UM, THAT THE PROBLEM
IS, YOU CAN'T EDUCATE PEOPLE
WHEN YOU PUT 20 PEOPLE INTO A B
INTO A BROOM CLOSET. AND UM, AS
WE SCALE DOWN THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THAT ALSO PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY. UH FOR US TO MAKE
THE INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO MAKE
AS A LEGISLATURE AND A STATE,
UH, TO CREATE THE TYPE OF SYS,
UH, THE INCARCERATION SYSTEM
THAT WE WANT, BECAUSE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO NEED TO BE INCARCERATED
. UM AND, UH, BECAUSE THAT IS A
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT, UH, THAT IS
EXPECTED FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
INJUSTICES. UH UH. BEEN UH, BEEN
, UH, HAVING INJUSTICES
INFLICTED UPON THEM? AND UH, SO
IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO LOOK AT
OUR FACILITIES, SEE WHAT NEEDS
TO BE REDONE AND COME UP WITH A
PLAN AND AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
OVER THE YEARS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. SO THAT THE, UH
THE OTHER GOAL THAT WE WANT CAN
ACTUALLY BE DONE BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T HAVE HUMANE FACILITIES
WHEN IT'S RAINING AS HARD
OUTSIDE OR INSIDE, AS IT IS
OUTSIDE, WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE
WITH SOME OF OURS. WE CAN'T HAVE
HUMANE FACILITIES WHERE YOU HAVE
TO BRING IN BOTTLED. BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE A WATER SYSTEM THAT'S
WORKING, RIGHT? UM SO THERE'S A
LOT OF, UM, ISSUES THAT ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES WITH OUR
OUR FACILITIES, AND THOSE NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED SO THAT WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF THE OTHER PARTS.
YOU CAN THROW ALL THE BODIES YOU
WANT INTO THOSE AS FAR AS IS OUR
CORRECTIONS OFFICERS AND SUCH,
BUT WITHOUT THE FACILITIES. WE
ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE THE
PROGRESS WE WANT. UH, TO CREATE
A CALIFORNIA MODEL. THAT THE
REST OF THE NATION CAN BE PROUD
OF AND FOLLOW. SO UM, THOSE ARE
THE THINGS I'M LOOKING AT. I I,
YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND. WE HAVE
A LOT OF, UH UM CUTS STILL ON
THE HORIZON. I'M A LITTLE
DISTRESSED ABOUT CHUCKWALLA
BEING ONE OF THE NEWER
FACILITIES. IT PROBABLY TAKE THE
LEAST TO REHAB. UM AND IN THE.
MEANWHILE WE'RE LEAVING
FACILITIES OPEN THAT ARE ALMOST
IN DIRE NEED OF BEING TORN DOWN.
UH, SO, UH, I. I REALLY LIKE US
TO FOCUS SOMEDAY ON ACTUALLY
MAKING A PLAN GOING FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE OUR OTHER
PLANS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS? ALL
RIGHT. UM BEFORE WE ESTABLISH
QUORUM, I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE HAVE, UM, UH,
CONFLICTS TODAY, UM, SO THEY
WILL BE STEPPING OUT. UH, WE
WILL CONTINUE THIS MEETING. UM,
HOPEFULLY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
OR WITH JUST ONE INDIVIDUAL, UH,
PRESIDING, SO I JUST WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR. THERE'S MORE,
INCLUDING MYSELF. I WILL BE
STEPPING OUT AS WELL. UM SO
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER HERE SO FAR
WILL HAVE TO STEP OUT. UM SO I
WOULD LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR WAHAN. HERE.
SENATOR DE RAZZO, SENATOR
NEWMAN, SENATOR SARTO. A CORUM
IS ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU. UH,
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST ISSUE
AND OVERVIEW OF èC Dð èC R S¼
BUDGET WITH SECRETARY UH
MCCUMBER. AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME. OK? SO,
I. I DO WANNA HIGHLIGHT AGAIN
THAT YOU WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
TO PRESENT. UM AND WE'RE GONNA
SET A TIMER AND I JUST I CHAIR
UH, PUBLIC SAFETY, AND I DO TIME
, EVERYBODY, SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE GETS
USED TO THAT. UM, AND PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU. CLEARLY I'M ON
. UH GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME A FEW
MINUTES TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF MY
PRIORITIES AND CHALLENGES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS SHARE.
UM SOME OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE, UH,
COMING FORTH, UH, BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE UM, OUR DEPARTMENT IS
NOT THE DEPARTMENT. WE WERE 20
YEARS AGO. UH YOU KNOW, WE'RE A
PART DEPARTMENT THAT NOW IS
DEDICATED TO FOSTERING A SAFER
AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT FOR, UH,
NOT ONLY FOLKS THAT WORK THERE,
BUT FOLKS THAT LIVE IN OUR
FACILITIES AS WELL, UM, AND AS
THE SENATOR MENTIONED EARLIER,
WE'RE HEAVILY INVESTED IN
DEVELOPING THE CALIFORNIA MODEL.
UH WELL, THAT'S TWO FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES, PRIORITIZING THE
WELL BEING OF OUR STAFF AND
SUPPORTING, UH, INDIVIDUALS. UH,
WHO ARE UNDER OUR CARE? SOME
QUICK èC èC R FACTS. UH WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INCARCERATING
ABOUT 92,000 INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
32 PRISONS AND 34 CONSERVATION
CAMPS. WE PROVIDE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING, VOCATIONAL TRAINING
, EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE
THROUGHOUT OUR FACILITIES. WE
ALSO HAVE ABOUT 35,000
INDIVIDUALS WE CURRENTLY HAVE ON
PAROLE, AS WELL AS RUNNING THE
PINE GROVE YOUTH CONFERENCE
CONSERVATION CAMP FOR COUNTY
YOUTH. WE'RE ALSO ONE OF THE
LARGEST APARTMENTS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT. UH, WE ENCOMPASS
ABOUT 41 MILLION SQUARE FEET OF
STATE OWNED OFFICE SPACE
COVERING OVER 21,000 ACRES WE
ALSO EMPLOY ABOUT 61,000
INDIVIDUALS. THE BUDGET BEFORE
YOU, UH FOR èC Dð èC R TOTAL
IS ABOUT 14.5 MILLION FOR 2425.
OF THAT AMOUNT. 4.1 BILLION IS
TIED TO HEALTH CARE, WHICH
INCLUDES NOT ONLY MEDICAL BUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND DENTAL AS
WELL. THE BULK OF THAT ONE MORE
TIME. HOW MUCH FOR MENTAL
HEALTH? UH OUR TOTAL FOR, UH,
MENTAL HEALTH IS $4.1 BILLION
FOR HEALTH CARE IS 4.1 BILLION,
WHICH INCLUDES MEDICAL, MENTAL
HEALTH AND DENTAL. AT ABOUT 10.5
BILLION OF OUR TOTAL BUDGET IS
TIED TO EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION,
WHICH INCLUDES BOTH SALARY AND
BENEFITS. LET'S COVER A FEW OF
MY PRIORITIES AND CHALLENGES,
UH, WERE WERE FACED WITH AS
YOU'VE HEARD, UH, OUR POPULATION
IS IN DECLINE. UM AS A RESULT, I
THINK OF NUMBER ONE ARE
INCREASED REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'D BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T SAY COVID. I ALSO
PLAYED A RATHER LARGE IMPACT IN
THAT REDUCTION. UM SINCE 2021
THROUGH PRISON CLOSURES, Dð JJ
CLOSURES AND OTHER SAVINGS
EFFORTS WE'VE SAVED OVER $500
MILLION. AND WE'RE AT A TIME AND
CORRECTIONS. I THINK WE HAVE A
ONCE IN A GENERATION OPPORTUNITY
TO CHANGE OUR SYSTEM. UM. I LIVE
THROUGH THE PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
WE HAD 100 AND 70 THREE 1000
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. WE HAD
GYMS FULL OF TRIPLE BUNKS AND
ALMOST NÓ PROGRAMMING. WE'RE AT
A DIFFERENT PLACE RIGHT NOW, UM
AND HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL AND GENERATIONAL
CHANGES TO THE DEPARTMENT. UH,
AND ONE OF THOSE, FOR EXAMPLE,
IS THE INVESTMENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE HELPED MAKE THROUGH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
WHERE WE NOT ONLY PROVIDE
MEDICATION ASSISTED THERAPY, BUT
, UH, COGNITIVE, COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS AS WELL
. UH, WE'RE AT A POINT NOW WHERE
WE HAVE 10,500 INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN COLLEGE. UM. WHICH
IS, UH, A REMARKABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
FOR HELPING US, UH, INVEST IN
LAPTOPS FOR THE POPULATIONS
WHICH WE CONTINUE TO ROLL OUT
AND I WITNESSED EARLIER THIS
WEEK. FOLKS CARRYING THAT
AROUND. IT MAY BE MOST
IMPORTANTLY. YOU'LL HEAR THE
NUMBER THAT CDCR HAS 15,000
VACANT BEDS. I WANNA BE CLEAR ON
MY PERSPECTIVE AND WHAT THAT
MEANS. THAT DOES NOT MEAN WE
HAVE EMPTY CELLS OR EMPTY BUNKS
WITH NÓ INDIVIDUALS IN THERE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE INMATE PURCELL AND ONE
INMATE PER BUNK. AT 100 AND
37.5% WHICH IS WHAT THAT NUMBER
WHEN YOU HEAR 15 TO 20,000
THROWN OUT. YOU HAVE MORE
INDIVIDUALS. DOUBLE CELLED. AND
DOUBLE BUNK THAN YOU DO SINGLE
CELL OR SINGLE BUNK. OUR VISION
AS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
IN PROMOTING NORMALIZATION IS TO
REDUCE OUR POPULATION TO PROVIDE
A MORE NORMALIZED ENVIRONMENT.
TO GIVE FOLKS A GREATER ACCESS
TO REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS, AND
WE CLOSE A PRISON. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HOUSE THEIR DO NOT
GO AWAY AND GO HOME. THEY ARE
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER PRISONS.
ALRIGHT TIME. OK UM, SO AGAIN.
THANK YOU. UH, I APOLOGIZE. I
WILL NOT BE AROUND FOR FURTHER
QUESTIONS. I HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
REAL REHABILITATIVE OVERSIGHT
BOARD TODAY. UM AND BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS DOWN
THE LINE. UH, IF NEEDED, DO YOU
HAVE ANY STAFF THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO ANSWER A QUESTION? WE
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF STAFF ARE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE TOPICS
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WELL.
AND IF YOU NEED ME TO ANSWER
ANYTHING NOW, I'M MORE THAN
WILLING. ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY, I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. I
UNDERSTAND. YOU HAVE TO LEAVE I.
I DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF THINGS AHEAD OF TIME.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE ANYBODY
WHO'S WATCHING THIS SUBCOMITTEE
IS AWARE OF THIS, UM FOR A ROUGH
DEPARTMENT OF $15 BILLION. THE
PROPOSED CUTS HAVE ONLY BEEN
SUGGESTED FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT
AT $2 MILLION. OF ELIMINATING
THE REDUCTION OF TRANS METRO BUS
CONTRACT. UH I WILL SAY THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A DEFICIT
IN THE BILLIONS, UM, THAT I'M
LOOKING FOR EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE REVIEWING IN THIS, UH, SUB
FIVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT A 15% CUT
ACROSS THE BOARD AND SO 2
MILLION DOESN'T CUT IT. AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT YOU GUYS
SHOULDER THE BURDEN YOURSELVES
RIGHT, BUT WE EXPECT A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THIS. RIGHT SO 15%
IS THE GOAL THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT FOR EVERYBODY. AND MADAM
CHAIR. I THINK OUR MY STAFF WILL
SHARE. IT'S MORE THAN 2 MILLION
IN OUR PROPOSALS AND THAT WILL
BE SHARED TODAY. AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT. UH, WE'RE
CLOSING THE CALIFORNIA CITY UH,
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY THIS YEAR
IN CHUCKWALLA VALLEY STATE
PRISON NEXT YEAR. UH, BOTH OF
THOSE SAVINGS ARE WELL IN EXCESS
OF $100 MILLION, AND BOTH ARE ON
TRACK FOR COMPLETION ON TIME, IF
NOT AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR BRAND NEW A FOCUS OF
AGAIN 15. OUR TEAM WILL BE
WORKING WITH ALL BUT I'M I'M
STATING IT NOW, AND I'M STATING
IT TO EVERYBODY THAT WE ARE.
THIS IS OUR GOAL. UM AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MORE ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS ON WHAT THAT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE FOR EACH
DEPARTMENT. RIGHT SO, UM, THE
OTHERS WERE REDUCTIONS OR COST
SAVINGS, UM, WHICH ARE DELAYS,
SO IT'S NOT EXACTLY NECESSARILY
CUT. SO I JUST WANNA BE VERY
FRANK WITH YOU AND HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND WE'RE VERY MUCH
OPEN TO HAVING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS. UM, AS WE MEET,
UH, THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO. ITEM NUMBER
TWO WILL COVER POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND CLOSURE PLANS.
FIRST WE WILL HEAR FROM èC Dð
èC R. WHO. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR JUSTIN EDELMAN, ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF BUDGET MANAGEMENT
BRANCH. IF IT'S OK WITH THE
COMMITTEE, I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO,
UM, SPLIT ITEM TWO INTO TWO KIND
OF SECTIONS. IT'S A PRETTY DENSE
TOPIC FIRST, I. I WANNA GO OVER
THE POPULATION PROJECTIONS AND
THEN MOVE INTO THE CLOSURE
DISCUSSION. OK, REMEMBER, WE
HAVE FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JANICE
SANFORD MILLER, AND I AM THE
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH. I'M HERE
TODAY TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF èC Dð èC R'S
FALL 2023 PROJECTIONS. UM THE
HANDOUT PROVIDED TO YOU INCLUDES
OUR CURRENT POPULATION
PROJECTIONS COMPARED TO THE 2023
BUDGET ACT. PROJECTIONS FOR YOUR
REFERENCE. OUR FULL PROJECTIONS
UTILIZE HISTORICAL TREND DATA,
INCLUDING DATA ON CORE
COMMITMENTS TO PREDICT FUTURE
POPULATIONS FOR MONITORING
PURPOSES. WE TRACK POINT OF TIME
POPULATIONS, UM, AT THE END OF
THE MONTH IN ORDER TO COMPARE
THE PROJECTED POPULATION TO THE
ACTUAL POPULATION, HOWEVER, FOR
BUDGETARY PURPOSES, WE UTILIZE
THE AVERAGE THE POPULATION OVER
THE FISCAL YEAR. THAT IS WHY
YOUR HANDOUT WILL NOTE THAT THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
PROJECTION CYCLE CURRENT YEAR
AND BUDGET YEAR REFLECT AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATIONS AND THE
REMAINING THREE YEARS REFLECT
JUNE 30TH POPULATIONS. THE FALL
POPULATION PROJECTIONS
ANTICIPATE THE INSTITUTION
POPULATION WILL DECREASE
THROUGHOUT THE PROJECTION CYCLE.
THE AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION IS
EXPECTED TO BE APPROXIMATELY
94,222. IN FISCAL YEAR. 2324 AND
91,000 185 AND 2425 THE FALL
PROJECTIONS ANTICIPATE THAT
ADMISSIONS WILL REMAIN
RELATIVELY STABLE THROUGHOUT THE
PROJECTION CYCLE AT
APPROXIMATELY 30,000 TO 30,600
ADMISSIONS PER YEAR. WE HAVE NOT
INCREASED, UH OBSERVED. EXCUSE
ME, AN INCREASING TREND IN
ADMISSIONS POST PANDEMIC, AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY EXPECTED. IN TERMS OF
PAROLE. WE EXPECT THE ACTIVE
PAROLE POPULATION WILL DECLINE
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR, 2526
INCREASED SLIGHTLY THE FOLLOWING
YEAR AND THEN STABILIZE,
REACHING APPROXIMATELY 35,182 BY
JUNE 30TH 2028. UM AS OF JANUARY
, 31ST OUR PAROLE POPULATION,
UM, SAT AT 35,194. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NÓ FURTHER
QUESTION OR STATEMENTS. DO WE
HAVE THE L Ó FOR COMMENT? THANK
YOU. ORLANDO SANCHEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OVERALL WE WITHHOLD
RECOMMENDATION ON THE POPULATION
SUGGESTS AS THEY WILL BE UPDATED
AT THE MAY REVISION. HOWEVER I
WILL SPEAK ON ONE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE, UH, THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO
CHANGE THE BUDGETING METHODOLOGY
FOR, UH, PAROLE SUPPORT STAFF.
THESE ARE POSITIONS THAT ARE NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN PAROLE
SUPERVISION. UH, BUT THEY
INCLUDE POSITIONS SUCH AS HUMAN
RESOURCE ANALYSTS AND OFFICE.
CONDITIONS UNDER THE PROPOSED
METHODOLOGY, NÓ ADJUSTMENTS
WOULD BE MADE WHEN THE
POPULATION IS BELOW 42,200. UM
AND IF THE POPULATION WERE TO
INCREASE ABOVE THAT 42,200
SUPPORT STAFF CHANGES WOULD BE
MADE ACCORDING TO THIS NEW
PROPOSED METHODOLOGY. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON THAT
FRONT. WE AGREE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT SOME OF THE
EXISTING METHODOLOGY NEEDS
REVISION. UM, GIVEN THAT SOME OF
THE WORKLOAD CHANGES, UH SOME OF
THE DECLINE IN THE POPULATION
CHANGE. SOME OF THE DECLINE IN
THE POPULATION IS AFFECTING. THE
DE THE DECREASE IN WORKLOAD. UH
HOWEVER, THE PROPOSED
METHODOLOGY WE FIND IS FLAWED
AND CREATES A MISMATCH BETWEEN
WHAT'S BUDGETED AND WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS. UM, AND THIS
WOULD RESULT IN THE DEPARTMENT
LIKELY BEING OVER BUDGETED. UH,
FOR SOME OF THESE POSITIONS AS
SUCH, WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT èC Dð èC R
TO SUBMIT A REVISED PROPOSAL AT
THE MAY REVISION THAT ACCOUNTS
FOR THE POPULATION DRIVEN
CHANGES AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT
POPULATION DRIVEN. THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION IF REQUESTED. THANK
YOU. ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? CYNTHIA
MENDOZA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
UM THIS CHANGE IN METHODOLOGY
FOR THE SUPPORT STAFF WILL
ESTABLISH A SET MINIMUM NUMBER
OF SUPPORT STAFF THAT WILL
REMAIN REGARDLESS IF THE
POPULATION CONTINUES TO DECREASE
. UM THERE IS ONGOING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD SUCH AS
PERSONNEL, UH, CONTRACTS,
PROCUREMENT FLEET SERVICES THAT
THE, UH, DEPARTMENT OF PAROLE
NEEDS TO MAINTAIN. UM,
REGARDLESS OF WHO WHO THEY'RE
SERVING IN THE VARIOUS AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE. SO THIS
PREMISE WOULD SET A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF SUPPORT STAFF THAT
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED AS THEIR SORT
OF AT THAT MINIMUM, AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE USED THE POPULATION.
UM, EXISTING TODAY. AND ALSO WE
THINK THAT THE CHANGE IN STAFF
MANAGEMENT RATIOS FROM 5 TO 1 TO
4 TO 1 WITH, UM, ALSO HELP THEM
IMPROVE SERVICES BECAUSE THOSE
ARE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD
DO MORE OF THE COMPLEX, ONGOING
WORKLOAD AND PROVIDE THAT
CONTINUITY FOR CHANGING STAFF
OVER TIME. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY CLOSING STATEMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT NOT ON POPULATION. OK
UH, I'LL OPEN IT UP TO THE REST
OF THE, UH, COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO OUR CLOSURE RELATED
PROPOSALS. UH, THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
UM, REQUEST A REDUCTION OF 33
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 2425
INCREASING TO 100 AND 31.6
MILLION GENERAL FUND. UM
ULTIMATELY, THIS WILL REDUCE
736.2 POSITIONS. UH, BEGINNING
IN 2526 ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CLOSURE OF CHUCKLE WAL VALLEY
STATE PRISON IN MARCH, 2025. UM
SIMILARLY, WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REDUCTION
ASSOCIATED WITH KIND OF THE
OVERALL BROADER PRISON CLOSURES
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. UH THAT WILL
BE A REDUCTION OF 9.6 MILLION
AND 57 POSITIONS IN 2425
INCREASING TO 11.1 MILLION AND
65 POSITIONS IN 2526, AND THESE
ARE MORE KIND OF ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS THAT HAVEN'T COME DOWN
IN PREVIOUS POSITIONS, SUCH AS
THE OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES
WHERE WE HAVE A ADMINISTRATIVE
ANALYSTS AT THE HEADQUARTERS
LEVEL WHO KIND OF WORK ON
INDIVIDUAL PRISONS, SO
CUMULATIVELY AS AS WE'VE CLOSED,
INSTITUTIONS AND FACILITIES WERE
REDUCING OUR HEADQUARTERS
FOOTPRINT AS WELL. UM, WITH ME,
I HAVE JARED LOZANO THE DIVISION
OR A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF DIVISION
SUPPORT OR FACILITY SUPPORT,
SORRY FOR THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS, AND DAVE LEWIS,
UH, DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES,
PLANNING AND CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. YOU GUYS HAVE FOUR
MINUTES LEFT. WE'RE WE'RE GOOD.
RIGHT. UM, CAN WE HAVE THE AAA
Ó? THANK YOU, CAITLIN O'NEILL
WITH THE L A Ó. WE DON'T HAVE
CONCERNS ON THESE. TO UH,
PROPOSALS TO REDUCE èC Dð èC R
FUNDING IN LINE WITH, UH,
PREVIOUS AND PLANNED FACILITY
DEACTIVATION. UH, MY COMMENTS
PERTAIN TO THE BROADER PICTURE
OF THE STATE'S NEED FOR PRISON
CAPACITY GOING FORWARD. AND AS
YOU'RE AWARE, SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN THE POPULATION
HAVE ALLOWED THE STATE TO
DEACTIVATE, UH, FACILITIES IN
RECENT YEARS. HOWEVER DESPITE
THESE REDUCTIONS, èC Dð èC R
S¼ PROJECTIONS CONTINUE TO SHOW
THAT THE POPULATION WILL REMAIN
WELL BELOW A COURT ORDERED LIMIT
ON THE POPULATION HOUSED AND
STATE OPERATED PRISONS. HOWEVER
IN RESPONSE TO SUGGESTIONS THAT
FURTHER CAPACITY REDUCTIONS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CITED THREE
MAIN CONCERNS IN THE PAST, WHICH
ARE INCREASED RISK OF VIOLATING
THE COURT-ORDERED POPULATION
LIMIT INCREASED COMPLEXITY AND
IDENTIFYING APPROPRIATE HOUSING
PLACEMENTS FOR PEOPLE BASED ON
THEIR VARIOUS SECURITY AND
INDIVIDUAL, HE HEALTHCARE AND
OTHER NEEDS, UM, AND A REDUCTION
IN THE NUMBER OF AVAILABLE
ASSIGNMENTS TO WORK SCHOOL AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS, AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WHEN CAPACITY IS REDUCED
IT NOT ONLY TAKES HOUSING UNITS
OUT OF OFFLINE. IT ALSO TAKES,
UM WORKSHOPS OR CLASSROOMS AND
WHATNOT IN THOSE FACILITIES OUT
OF USE AS WELL. IN RESPONSE TO
THESE CONCERNS, THE 2020 THREE
24 BUDGET PACKAGE REQUIRED èC
Dð èC R TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE WITH AN ANALYSIS
OF ITS CAPACITY NEEDS. THAT
REPORT, SUBMITTED IN NOVEMBER
WAS PRIMARILY AN INVENTORY OF
THE NUMBER OF ASSIGNMENTS THAT
èC Dð èC R HAS, UM, BASED ON
ITS EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FUNDING LEVELS. AS WELL AS A
CALCULATION OF THE PERCENT OF
THE POPULATION THAT COULD BE UH,
THAT COULD HAVE A FULL TIME
ASSIGNMENT AT DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF, UM, PRISON DENSITY. AND
OVERALL AFTER REVIEWING THAT
REPORT, AS WELL AS OTHER
INFORMATION RELEVANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STATED CONCERNS
, WE FOUND THAT, UM, FURTHER
CAPACITY THAT THEY'RE CONCERNS
WITH FURTHER CAPACITY REDUCTIONS
COULD BE MITIGATED, FOR EXAMPLE,
REDUCTIONS TO THE NUMBER OF FULL
TIME ASSIGNMENTS COULD BE
MITIGATED BY BUILDING ADDITIONAL
CLASSROOMS OR CREATING NEW
ASSIGNMENTS THAT DON'T REQUIRE
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
WHILE MITIGATING THE CONCERNS,
UH, COULD CREATE SOME NEW STATE
COSTS. WE THINK THEY WOULD
LARGELY BE TEMPORARY IN NATURE
AND, UH, SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN
THE NEARLY $1 BILLION IN ANNUAL
COST TO OPERATE, UH, UP UP TO
FIVE PRISONS THAT COULD BE
CLOSED BASED ON THE PROJECTION
WHAT THE PROJECTIONS ARE
SHOWING. UM FINALLY, WE FIND
THAT STATE LAW UM WHICH REQUIRES
CDCR TO ACCOMMODATE PROJECTED
POPULATION DECLINES BY REDUCING
CAPACITY IN A MANNER THAT
MAXIMIZES LONG TERM SAVINGS
ARGUABLY REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
TO REDUCE CAPACITY AT THIS POINT
, UH, ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT èC Dð
èC R TO BEGIN PLANNING TO
REDUCE CAPACITY AND TO REPORT
ON, UM HOW TO MITIGATE ANY
RESULTING CHALLENGES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CAN WE GET THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? THANK YOU
. LENNY SHIMO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT PROPOSED ANY ADDITIONAL
CLOSURES AT THIS TIME, AND I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DISAGREES WITH
THE NEED TO BRING èC Dð èC R
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH PENAL CODE
2067 AS WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
ALREADY IN COMPLIANCE. PENAL
CODE 2067 REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER CERTAIN
FACTORS WHEN DETERMINING WHETHER
TO CLOSE PRISONS, BUT IT'S A
NONEXCLUSIVE LIST. THE
DEPARTMENT CONSIDERS THOSE
FACTORS IDENTIFIED, BUT IT IS
NOT LIMITED TO ONLY CONSIDERING
THOSE FACTORS AND THE LANGUAGE.
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE DEPARTMENT
FROM MAINTAINING A LARGER BUFFER
THAN THE FEDERAL COURT ORDER.
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ITS CAPACITY
ASSESSMENT AND MID NOVEMBER
WHICH INCLUDED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON REHABILITATION AT
VARYING LEVELS OF CROWDING. UM
AND AS èC Dð èC R CONTINUES TO
IMPLEMENT THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
STATEWIDE, THE POPULATION
DECLINE HAS REALLY GIVEN THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ALTER THEIR VIEW
ON CAPACITY, LOOKING FURTHER
THAN JUST THE NUMBER OF BEDS AND
THE RESULTING BUFFER BUT
INCLUDING SOME NORMALIZATION BY
BRINGING THE PRISON EXPERIENCE
CLOSER, UH TO LIFE OUTSIDE ITS
WALLS, AND THAT MEANS LESS
CROWDING AND AS A RESULT, LESS
DOUBLE SELLING, WHICH IMPROVES
THE LIVING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
INCARCERATED AS WELL AS THE
WORKING ENVIRONMENT FOR STAFF.
AS THERE ARE FEWER PEOPLE HOUSED
PER PRISON, AND IT ALSO ALLOWS
FOR A GREATER LEVEL OF
PROGRAMMING BECAUSE IT FEWER
PEOPLE WILL BE COMPETING FOR THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY. ULTIMATELY THE
POPULATION SO FAR EXCEEDS THE
DESIGN CAPACITY OF ONE
INCARCERATED PERSON PER CELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU GUYS
HAVE CLOSING REMARKS. IN THE
CLOSING. UM, I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS. QUESTION.
UM, CHECK A WALLER. WHY THAT
FACILITY ISN'T THAT ONE OF OUR
NEWER FACILITIES. YOU CAN ANSWER
IT. NÓ IS IT? WE HAVE A LOT OF
DILAPIDATED FACILITIES ARE
STAYING OPEN, AND WE SEEM TO BE
CLOSING NEW FACILITIES THAT ARE
MUCH MORE. TENABLE FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE, SIR. UM
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION. UM
CHUCK WALL IS ONE OF, UM, IN THE
NEW BUILD CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
THAT WAS TOOK PLACE IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES. UM CCA
WALLA. THE FACTORS THAT WERE
CONSIDERED AROUND THE CLOSURE OF
CHWALA INCLUDE THE AVAILABILITY
OF PROGRAMMING THE AVAILABILITY
OF STAFF, UM, THE LEVEL AND THE
NEED FOR THE BEDS. UM,
UNFORTUNATELY, UM, FOR CHUA
WALLA. YOU KNOW, BEING A DORMED
FACILITY? UM IN THE PANDEMIC, WE
FOUND THE THAT, UM, TYPE OF
FACILITY WAS LESS CONDUCIVE TO
THE OPERATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
. UM DUE TO, UM YOU KNOW,
VENTILATION AND OTHER FACTORS
RELATED TO THAT, UM AND CHUA
WALL IS ALMOST ENTIRELY A DORM
FACILITY AND ALSO THE LOW
CUSTODY LEVEL. SO UM OTHER
FACILITIES PROVIDE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE THE
PROGRAMMING THAT'S EXPECTED, UM,
AND AN ENVIRONMENT UM, THAT, UH,
SUPPORTS THAT. LEVEL OF
PROGRAMMING, SO THERE'S A MANY
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT LED TO
THE CLOSURE OF THE SELECTION OF
CHUA WALLER. UM AND I'VE I'VE
JUST LISTED A FEW OF THEM, BUT,
UM, OTHER THINGS, UM,
AVAILABILITY OF HEALTH CARE
STAFF TO PROVIDE PROGRAMMING THE
ABILITY TO PLACE UM, THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION AS WE'VE
DECREASED THE POPULATION, THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS, UM, HAS
INCREASED, UM, AS A PROPORTION
OF THE POPULATION AND WE'RE VERY
RESTRICTED FROM PLACING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN DESERT
INSTITUTIONS AND DUE TO THE
TEMPERATURES AND THE
INTERACTIONS WITH THEIR
MEDICATIONS THAT THEY TAKE, AND
SO ALL THOSE THINGS LED TO A
DECISION. UM THAT CH A WALL IT
WAS INAPPROPRIATE INSTITUTION TO
CLOSE SIMILAR FACTORS RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA CITY AS WELL. UM AND
THAT WAS ALSO AT LEASE FACILITY.
SO IT HAD. WE WEREN'T NEEDING TO
SUPPORT THAT, IN THE LONG TERM
ALSO LED TO THAT DECISION AS
WELL. BUT I CAN LEAVE TURN TO
MY, UM, PARTNER TO ABOUT ANY
OPERATIONAL ISSUES. SO. I THINK
THEY'VE HIT MOST OF THEM. BUT I
WOULD ALSO, UH, I THINK THE
BIGGEST ONE IS THE SECURITY
LEVEL AS WELL AS ANY ACCESS. YOU
KNOW, LIKE A Dð A COMPLIANCE.
WHAT? WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE FOR
INCARCERATED POPULATION. BUT
MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL IN THE
DESERT IS REALLY REALLY, UH, A
BIG ONE. AND OF COURSE, WHEN I
SAY SECURITY DORMED èC L OR
DORM LIVING VERSUS CELL LIVING
IN WHAT THE NEEDS ARE THERE SO
ALRIGHT, WELL, I HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET OUT THERE, BUT IT'S
IRONWOOD. RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO IT.
CORRECT? YES. SO IRONWOOD STAYS
OPEN. CORRECT. AND THAT IS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S POINT.
AS FAR AS PENAL CODE. 2067 IS
THE WORKFORCE IMPACT, SO TO
MINIMIZE THAT WORKFORCE IMPACT
BY CLOSING A CO LOCATED
INSTITUTION, IT'S I MEAN, IT'S
AN ISOLATED AREA. THE CITY OF
BLYTHE, I THINK DEPENDS ON IT.
AND IN SOME RESPECTS, UM BUT
YOU, YOU KNOW, THE CITY OF
BLYTHE IS BEGGING NOT TO CLOSE
IT AND THE OTHER CITIES THAT
HAVE A PRISON AND ARE BEGGING TO
CLOSE IT, AND, UH, YOU KNOW, IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT SOME OF
THE MITIGATION ISSUES, UH ARE
WITH ONE OF OUR NEWER FACILITIES
. UH I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THOSE WOULD NOT RELATE TO SOME
OF OUR OLDER FACILITIES AS WELL.
UH, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
COVID, AND I UNDERSTAND THE DORM
ISSUE, BUT GUESS WHAT, UM,
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO. THAT'S WHAT OUR MORE HUMANE
POLICY IS TO MAKE IT SO IT'S NOT
SUCH SO PRISON UM. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE DOWN THE ONE THAT
ISN'T AND SO IT IT. IT KIND OF
CONCERNS ME THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S THE ONE THAT SHOWS THAT
WAS CHOSEN TO BE BE CLOSED DOWN.
UM, BECAUSE I THINK IT HAS AS
FAR AS BEING ABLE TO PUT IN MORE
PROGRAMMING AND STUFF. WELL,
PROGRAMMING IS PUTTING IN
BUILDINGS. AND UH, THAT'S WHAT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT BY UPDATING
SOME OF HIS FACILITIES SO THAT
WE CAN BETTER FACILITATE. UH
WOULD BE BETTER THAN GOING FROM
YOUR DORM ROOM TO A BUILDING. IT
LOOKS LIKE AN EDUCATION FACILITY
TO LEARN. UM AND IT IS WARM OUT
THERE, BUT WE'RE PUTTING A LOT
OF THINGS OUT THERE THAT ARE
WARM, AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
ALL THEIR ELECTRIFICATION OF
EVERYTHING SO STILL, UM I, I I'M
STILL CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
PRISON. AND UH AND MAYBE, UH, I
CAN GET TOGETHER WITH YOU GUYS
AND DO A LITTLE BIT OF A TOUR
AND WE'LL FIGURE WE'LL WE'LL
LOOK AT IT MORE IN DEPTH THAN
YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ME A LITTLE
BIT MORE. WHY WHY THAT VERSUS
SOME OF THE OTHER ONES THAT
PEOPLE ARE BEGGING TO HAVE
CLOSED IN THEIR CITIES. THANK
YOU. UH, WE I. I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT THAT. YES, SENATOR DE
RAZA, GO AHEAD. UM, I JUST
WANTED TO SAY, I REMEMBER IN THE
PAST ONE OF THE ISSUES WAS, UM,
MAINTENANCE AND UPGRADES. UH,
THE COST OF THOSE, UH, WAS
ALWAYS AN AN ISSUE EITHER. TO
CLOSE OR NOT CLOSE, BUT I KNOW
WE WERE ALWAYS ASKING THAT
QUESTION. DID THAT HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THIS DECISION? AND
GENERALLY INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
CONDITION OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS A FACTOR THAT'S CONSIDERED,
UM BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT EVEN OUR NEW BUILD
CONSTRUCTION WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF, UM èC, HÌ, èC F AND OUR
INFILL PROJECTS AT MULE CREEK
AND RJ Dð. MOST OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS ARE APPROACHING 30
YEARS OLD. AND SO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES ARE VERY
SIMILAR AT OUR SO CALLED NEWER
INSTITUTIONS COMPARED TO OUR
OLDER INSTITUTIONS AND IN SOME
WAYS MORE ACUTE. UM BECAUSE OF
THE DESIGN AND THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THOSE FACILITIES COMPARED TO
SOME OF THE OLDER FACILITIES
THAT WERE BUILT, MAYBE A LITTLE
MORE HARDY IN THE BEGINNING AND
HAD SIMPLER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
EASIER TO MAINTAIN. UM WHEREAS
OUR NEWER INSTITUTIONS THE
SYSTEMS ARE FAIRLY COMPLEX, AND
WE'RE REACHING THAT END OF LIFE
KIND OF CYCLE ON A LOT OF OUR
NEWER SO CALLED NEWER
INSTITUTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. I DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
TO THE PUBLIC THAT, UM, ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS OF CLOSING FIVE
PRISONS WOULD EQUATE TO A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR SAVINGS.
SO UM, JUST HIGHLIGHTING THAT
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN TAKING
PLACE AS WELL. UH WE WELCOME YOU
ALL TO MEET WITH ANY ONE OF US,
UM, AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THE RE
APPROPRIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REALITY. BASED TRAINING CENTER
FUNDING. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM èC Dð èC R. YEAH.
THIS REQUEST IS TO REAPPROPRIATE
FROM THE 2021 BUDGET ACT, 8.5
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO COMPLETE
RENOVATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
REALITY BASED TRAINING CENTER IN
UH STOCKTON. AND WITH ME, I AM
JOINED BY. UH, CHRISTINA ORTIZ,
UM, CORRECTIONAL BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL BE
TIMING YOU ALL FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UM
AND GOOD MORNING. UM I'M S¼
BEFORE I THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME COME TO DISCUSS THIS. UM, WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT 8.5 MILLION
THAT WAS APPROVED IN OUR 2122 B
èC P TO, UH, ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA REALITY BASED
TRAINING CENTER. WE MOVED TO
2425 AND 2526 SPLIT IN 4 MILLION
AND 2425 AND 4.5 MILLION AND
2526. THIS WOULD UM HELP US TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THE CALIFORNIA
REALITY BASED TRAINING CENTER
STAND ALONE FACILITY AS WE HAD
ENVISIONED IN THE ORIGINAL B èC
P. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE, UH,
COMMENTS FROM L? A Ó FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ALL RIGHT
, SEE? NONE. DO WE HAVE ANY? DO
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS?
CLOSING COMMENTS? ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY FROM THE
COMMITTEE? ALL RIGHT, UM. HOW
MUCH TIME WOULD A CADET IN THE
ACADEMY SPEND TRAINING AT THIS
FACILITY? AS OF RIGHT NOW, IT'S
102 HOURS. UM, WE'RE HOPING TO
HAVE IT MORE AND WE WANT TO DO
IT, UM, BASICALLY HALF AND HALF
RIGHT HALF LECTURE AND HALF
REALITY BASED, SO THAT WAY THEY
CAN HEAR WHAT THEY HAVE TO WHAT
THEIR INSTRUCTIONS ARE AND THEN
GO TO THE FACILITY AND ACTUALLY,
UH, PRACTICE THEM SO ROUGHLY
THREE WEEKS IT'S A 13 WEEK
ACADEMY. SO RIGHT NOW IT'LL BE
ROUGHLY SIX WEEKS. UM AND SINCE
THIS PROJECT WAS PROPOSED,
SEVERAL OTHER èC Dð èC R
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN DEACTIVATED
, INCLUDING YARDS AND OPERATING
PRISONS. WHY IS RENOVATING THIS
FACILITY? STILL THE BEST OPTION.
THIS FACILITY IS ABOUT 30
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE ACTUAL
ACADEMY, SO IT'S ONE OF THE
CLOSEST ONES. IT'S ALSO ONE THAT
, UM, MIRRORS A LOT. MOST OF THE
èC THE èC Dð èC R, UM,
PRISONS, UM AND IT GIVES THE
OTHER AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
CLOSED ARE JUST, YOU KNOW, YARDS
AND SO THAT WOULDN'T BE ENOUGH
ROOM FOR US TO USE THE WHOLE
PLACE. SO WHAT ABOUT THE CLOSED
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FACILITIES, WHICH ARE ALSO IN
STOCKTON, WHERE SOME STAFF FROM
THE CLOSED HEALTH CARE FACILITY
ALREADY TRAIN? THE CLOSED Dð JJ
FACILITY WAS NOT CLOSED AT THE
TIME WHEN WE HAD PUT IN THE 2122
B èC P. UM IT ALSO HAS. IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME LAYOUT AS
A èC Dð èC R FACILITY. DOES IT
HAS A IT'S A Dð JJ LOCATION, SO
IT HAS LOOKS MORE LIKE THE
JUVENILES. SO WHAT ABOUT USING A
CLOSED YARD AT AN OPERATING
FACILITY? WE WOULD NEED TO USE
THE WHOLE FACILITY IN ORDER TO
DO THE TRAINING THAT WE ENVISION
FOR OUR CADETS. ALL RIGHT. UM,
IS THERE ANY ABILITY TO CHANGE
THAT VISION AND ADAPT TO
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES? AT THIS
TIME. I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. UM IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN LOOK INTO. AND I CAN
DEFINITELY GET BACK TO YOU GUYS,
BUT DEFINITELY NÓ. I APPRECIATE
THAT. I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
AND I THINK YOU KNOW A LITTLE
MORE BRAINSTORMING ON WHAT WE
CAN DO. UH, GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE HAVE NOW,
UH, THANK YOU, AND WE'LL MOVE TO
ITEM. UH, NUMBER FOUR. THANK YOU
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR. I DO WANT
TO NOTE UH, CORRECTION AS A READ
THE REQUEST RIGHT NOW. THE B èC
P REQUEST 21.9 MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN 2425 AND ONGOING THERE
WAS A TECHNICAL ERROR THAT 21.9
MILLION GENERAL FUNDS SHOULD
JUST BE FOR 2425 AND THEN
INCREASE TO, UM 40 THREE 0.8
MILLION GENERAL FUND. IT'S A 50%
REDUCTION IN THE BUDGET YEAR,
BUT THE FUNDING IS REQUESTED TO
ADDRESS, UM INCREASING UTILITIES
COSTS THAT WE'VE SEEN SYSTEM
WIDE. OK, DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM LAL? YES THANK
YOU. UM WE FIND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED NEW
METHODOLOGY TO BUDGET FOR
UTILITY COSTS APPEARS REASONABLE
AND THAT THE ARGUMENT PROPOSED
AUGMENTATION APPEARS REASONABLE.
HOWEVER IF UTILITY COSTS END UP
BEING LOWER THAN BUDGETED, THE
DEPARTMENT COULD REDIRECT THE
FUNDING TO OTHER PURPOSES, GIVEN
THAT IT'S BUDGETED IN A LARGE
ITEM, UH SO WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE PROPOSAL BUT
ADOPTING PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE ANY ACCESS FUND, UH,
UTILITIES FUNDING TO REVERT TO
THE GENERAL FUND. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE? PATRICK
PLANT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UH,
THE INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
USE A METHODOLOGY THAT ALLOWS
BUDGETING TO BE AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE TO THE ACTUAL COSTS. UH
èC Dð èC R INCURS FOR
UTILITIES. FOR THIS REASON
ADOPTING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
REVERT EXCESS FUNDING TO THE
GENERAL FUND IS NOT NECESSARY AT
THIS TIME, ADJUSTING THE
ESTIMATED AMOUNT BASED ON THE
ACTUAL COST OF THE PREVIOUS 12
MONTHS WILL RESULT IN A BETTER
ALIGNED BUDGET FOR UTILITY COSTS
. AND AS THEY LLE Ó POINTED OUT
IN ITS ANALYSIS, UTILITIES ARE
CLOSELY LINKED TO THE
MAINTAINING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE AND
WORK IN èC Dð èC R FACILITIES.
WHICH IS OF UTMOST CONCERN FOR
èC, Dð, èC, R AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE BELIEVE THIS
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. ALL RIGHT, UM
AND GIVEN OUR OUR COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS REGARDING SOLAR AND
MUCH MORE, UH, WHAT IS èC Dð
èC R DOING TO GENERATE ITS OWN
POWER. SUCH AS UTILIZING SOLAR
AND SO FORTH. WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS AND I CAN
I CAN WORK WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
TO GET YOU THAT LIST OF
INSTITUTIONS THAT DO HAVE SOLAR
OR WIND POWER, AND WE ARE
CONSTANTLY EXPLORING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREENER,
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY SOURCES. AND
HOW HAS THE DEPARTMENT BEEN
ABSORBING THE COST OVERRUN SO
FAR, INCLUDING THE EXTRA COST
LEFT UNFUNDED BY THIS B èC P.
SO LAST TWO YEARS AGO IN THE
2022 BUDGET ACT, WE ACTUALLY
ASKED FOR AN INCREASE IN
UTILITIES COSTS THEN AS WELL,
AND AT THAT TIME WE HAD BUILT IN
A METHODOLOGY TO JUST ANNUALLY
FOR THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
UNFORTUNATELY UTILITIES AND
ELECTRICITY COSTS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXCEEDED THOSE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX ADJUSTMENTS
, SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE COMING
FORWARD WITH THIS REQUEST AS FAR
AS HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ABSORB
THE EXISTING COSTS THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THOSE INCREASES. UM
LARGELY, IT HAS TO DO WITH KIND
OF THE SHUTTING DOWN OF
FACILITIES OR INSTITUTIONS AND
REALIZING SOME SAVINGS AS WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO OPERATIONALIZE
THOSE A LITTLE EARLIER, SO, TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE'VE HAD, YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL SAVINGS IN PLAN
OPERATIONS, STAFF OR FACILITY
COSTS IS IF THIS REQUEST WERE
APPROVED, AND THE DEPARTMENT NÓ
LONGER HAD TO ABSORB THE COST,
WHAT MONEY WOULD BE FREED UP?
AND WHAT IS THE MONEY SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR THE MONEY COULD BE
USED FOR A NUMBER OF THINGS
LARGELY IN PLAN OPERATIONS, SO
THOSE WOULD BE SALARIES AND
WAGES FOR, YOU KNOW, UM
ENGINEERS OR PLANT OPERATIONS
STAFF AGAIN AT THE INSTITUTIONS.
ALL RIGHT. UM ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? SENATOR CLARA. SO TO
SUM IT UP. WE HAVE LESS. WE HAVE
HALF AS MANY PRISONERS. WE TOOK
IN A BUNCH OF BUILDINGS OFFLINE.
ARE WE USING MORE MORE ENERGY
THAN WE USED TO USE, AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE WE'VE INCURRED THESE
COSTS OR IS IT STRICTLY THE COST
OF LIVING? IT'S LARGELY A COST
INCREASE. SO IT'S LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE IN CALIFORNIA IS FEELING
THAT SAME INSIGNIFICANTLY LAST
YEAR FROM FROM OUR IN JANUARY,
23. EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING WE
CAN DO ABOUT THIS. NOTHING THEY
CAN DO ABOUT THIS. THEY'RE JUST
ABSORBING OUR OUR ENERGY POLICY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS? NÓ CLOSING COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE TO, UM,
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. HEALTHCARE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SO FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM èC Dð èC R AGAIN A
COLLECTIVELY YOU GUYS HAVE FIVE
MINUTES, OK? GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DANE
READER, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FISCAL SERVICES FOR, UH,
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL, HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. UM OUR FIRST ITEM
IS WE'RE REQUESTING A 40,000,001
TIME AUGMENTATION FOR 2425 TO
SHORE UP PERSONAL SERVICES
FUNDING. WE HAVE HAD A
DEFICIENCY IN OUR BUDGET FOR THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. UM SO WE HAVE A
PROGRAM STRUCTURAL ISSUE, UM,
LARGELY DRIVEN BY WORKERS COMP.
LUMP SUM PAYMENTS, OVERTIME AND
REGISTRY UTILIZATION TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE CARE AND COVER STAFF
VACANCIES. UM. IN ADDITION TO
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM SHORTFALL,
WE ARE ALSO REQUESTING 36.5
MILLION FOR CONTRACT MEDICAL
COSTS. UM AND A REDUCTION IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY. UM, WE
HAVE HAD A METHODOLOGY BASED ON
A PER INMATE COST FOR CONTRACT
MEDICAL, AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT
DRIVE OF A HUGE GAP IN OUR
CONTRACT MEDICAL BUDGET LARGELY
DRIVEN BY, UM OUR HIGH HIGH RISK
PATIENTS STAYING INTO THE SYSTEM
WHICH DRIVE MORE CONTRACT
MEDICAL, SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
ESTABLISH A NEW METHODOLOGY THAT
IS BASED ON AN ACUITY RATE
VERSUS A YOU KNOW, PER INMATE
RATE TO SHORE UP THAT GAP IN OUR
BUDGET AS WELL. THE REDUCTION IN
REIMBURSEMENT IS LARGELY DRIVEN
BY OUR PATIENTS THAT GO OUT FOR
HOSPITAL STAYS FOR MORE THAN 24
HOURS. WITH THE REDUCTIONS IN
OVERALL POPULATION, WE'VE SEEN
LESS FOLKS. UM OUR PATIENTS.
EXCUSE ME GOING OUT TO THE, UM
HOSPITALS WHICH HAS DRIVEN US
NOT TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT
REIMBURSEMENT AT THE LEVELS THAT
WERE PRE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED.
UM, WITH ME TODAY IS DOCTOR KAN,
UM, OVER CLINICAL OPERATIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT, AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. UH, DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE L A Ó? ORLANDO SANCHEZ
WITH THE LAL IN REGARDS TO THE
FIRST PROPOSAL, THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM SHORTFALL WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
PROPOSAL. WE FIND THAT IN RECENT
YEARS THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO ADDRESS ITS OVERSPENDING
WITHIN WITHOUT NEEDING AN
AUGMENTATION TO ITS BUDGET.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
MAKE IT CLEAR WHY THE DEPARTMENT
CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO SO IN THE
IN THE FUTURE. IN ADDITION, EVEN
IF THE DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE A
SHORTFALL, UH AND IT CAN ADDRESS
BUT ADDRESS IT BY REDIRECTING
SAVINGS HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
PAST. UH THEY CAN SEEK
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THROUGH ITEM
9840 IN THE BUDGET BILL OR
REQUEST THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THROUGH A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION THAT WOULD STILL
HAVE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. BUT
FINALLY, THE DEPARTMENT DID NOT
PROVIDE ADEQUATE JUSTIFICATION
ON HOW IT ARRIVED AT THAT 40
MILLION PROJECTED ESTIMATE. AND
IN REGARDS TO THE SECOND
PROPOSAL WE HEARD TODAY. UM, WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL
UNTIL IT IS ADJUSTED BASED ON
UPDATED, UH, POPULATION
PROJECTIONS THROUGH THE STANDARD
BIANNUAL ADJUSTMENT PROCESS. IN
ADDITION, WE FIND THAT SOME
PORTIONS OF THE FOUR OF THE
PROPOSAL DO NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
POPULATION, SPECIFICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS AND THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS UNDER THE
PROPOSED. UM FUNDING THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD RECEIVE FUNDING
AT A CONSTANT LEVEL IN THE OUT
YEARS, AND WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT èC Dð èC R
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE POPULATION
BOTH THE SIZE AND THE MAKEUP. UM
IN IN A REVISED ADJUSTMENT AND
IN THE SPRING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CERVANTES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WILL BE SPEAKING TO THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM SHORTFALL AND MY
COLLEAGUE WILL BE SPEAKING TO
THE OTHER PROPOSAL. UM, SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS REQUESTED TO COVER A
PROJECTED SHORTFALL WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM, AND IT PROVIDES
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH
ADDITIONAL TIME, UH TO IDENTIFY
ONGOING SOLUTIONS NEEDED TO
SUSTAIN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM LONG
TERM, RELYING RELYING ON THE
UTILIZATION OF SAVINGS FROM
OTHER PROGRAMS IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION, NOR IS IT
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE. IT ALSO
DOES NOT SOLVE THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THIS BUDGETARY SHORTFALL IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
ITEM 9840 FUNDING WOULD NOT
TYPICALLY BE AVAILABLE, UH, FOR
THESE PURPOSES AS THESE FUNDS
ARE SPECIFICALLY SET ASIDE FOR
UNANTICIPATED COSTS, CONSIDERING
THE ADMINISTRATION IS, UM
PROPOSING THIS PROPOSAL WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, AND THERE
HAVE BEEN FUNDING SHORTFALLS IN
THE PAST FEW YEARS. IT WOULD BE
CHALLENGING TO IDENTIFY THESE
COSTS AS UNANTICIPATED. GOOD
MORNING, JOSHUA WHITMER HOUSE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REGARDING
THE SECOND PROPOSAL FOR CONTRACT
MEDICAL COSTS, AS NOTED BY THE L
A Ó èC Dð èC R POPULATION
PROJECTIONS WILL BE UPDATED THE
MAY REVISION AND THIS REQUEST.
WOULD BE UPDATED TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE ARE SUBSTANTIVE OR
MATERIAL CHANGES REQUIRING
REVISION REGARDING SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE MINISTRY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL RELIES
ON USING HISTORICAL AVERAGES AS
THE BASIS FOR THE ADJUSTMENT
PROPOSED FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
CLAIMS AND MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS. WE BELIEVE
THIS IS ALSO A RESP REASONABLE
MEANS FOR ADJUSTING FUNDING
LEVELS FOR THESE PURPOSES BEYOND
PURELY TYING THE METHODOLOGY TO
THE POPULATION COUNT.
PARTICULARLY IN THE CASE OF
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. èC Dð
èC R IS ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT FOR VERY
SPECIFIC CONTRACT MEDICAL
SERVICES, AS THEY ALLUDED TO,
EVEN IN THIS CASE, THE USE OF
HISTORICAL AVERAGES WOULD
ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES IN THE
POPULATION. THE PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO MAKE SURE
ADEQUATE FUNDING LEVELS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT TO
FUND CONTRACT. MEDICAL SERVICES.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU, UM. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS, I. I SPECIFICALLY
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
CITED UH, REGISTERING OVERTIME
COSTS A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
DRIVING OVERSPENDING IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM BUDGET. WHAT A
èC Dð èC R DONE TO IMPROVE THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
CIVIL SERVICE WORKERS OR THERE
ANY CERTAIN INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE PARTICULARLY HARD TO RECRUIT
AT. AND WHAT ABOUT TELEHEALTH
OPTIONS? UM, WITH ME TODAY. IS
JACINDA MUHAMMAD FROM OUR HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT THAT CAN
SPEAK TO SOME OF OUR RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS. UM WE'VE DONE OUR BEST
TO EXPAND TELEMEDICINE, UM, INTO
DIFFERENT AREAS TO, UM. INCREASE
HIRING AND SO TELEMEDICINE HAS
CONTINUED TO EXPAND OVER TIME,
AND WE'VE DONE A FEW PROPOSALS.
UM, SURROUNDING THAT. AS FAR AS
THE VACANCY AND RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JACINDA MOHAMMED, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HUMAN RESOURCES FOR
HEALTH CARE, UM, THE VACANCY
RATE CHALLENGES CHANGE,
DEPENDING ON GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION
, PARTICULAR CLASSIFICATIONS. UM
SOME OF OUR CHALLENGES ARE
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AS WE'VE
EXPERIENCED NATIONWIDE SHORTAGES
IN THOSE CLASSIFICATIONS, WHAT
WE'VE DONE TO INCREASE
RECRUITMENT ACROSS THE BOARD IS
TO BUILD OUT OUR ADVERTISEMENT
AND MARKETING. UM CREATING A
BRANDING, UM, CAMPAIGN WHERE
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE IS A
CAREER PATHWAY OF CHOICE AND
THAT WE ARE AN EMPLOYER OF
CHOICE. UH, WE HAVE INCREASED
OUR OUTREACH TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES GETTING AHEAD OF
THE GRADUATING STUDENTS, UH,
THAT WE CAN SHARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST IN, UH,
CORRECTIONS WHERE YOU'RE HAVING
ACCESS TO A DIVERSE POPULATION,
UM, OF PATIENTS AND, UM CAREER
PATHWAYS. ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DID IN 2022 WAS WE CREATED A END
TO END HIRING EVENT. AND WHAT
THAT DID WAS BREAK DOWN THE KIND
OF SILOS AND WALLS OF CIVIL
SERVICE PROCESS AND CANDIDATES
COULD COME INTO A LOCATION. UH,
WE PICK LOCATIONS CENTRALLY, UH,
GEOGRAPHIC TO OUR INSTITUTIONS
AND CANDIDATES COULD COME IN AND
TAKE A CIVIL SERVICE EXAM. THEY
COULD SIT FOR AN INTERVIEW. UH
GET A PREEMPLOYMENT OFFER A
CONTENTION. OFFER AND MOVE RIGHT
INTO PREEMPLOYMENT. WHAT'S YOUR
VACANCY RATE? UM, OUR VACANCY
RATE. I'LL HAVE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BACK TO YOU. I THINK
WE'RE A WRITER. AROUND ABOUT 24%
STATEWIDE. UM, BUT I CERTAINLY
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THOSE
NUMBERS, OK? AND THEN WHAT IS
YOUR, UM, YOU KNOW, UH,
TURNOVER. I DON'T HAVE RETENTION
NUMBERS, UM, AVAILABLE TODAY. UM
I ALSO CAN PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION ON THAT, UH, A LATER
. TIME AND I. I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL
IS THAT WE HAVE SHORTAGES IN
WORKERS IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
CLASSIFICATIONS. WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF TEACHERS, DOCTORS,
POLICE OFFICERS, UM YOU NAME IT
RIGHT, INCLUDING, UM MEDICAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND SO
FORTH. UM I WILL SAY THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS, UH, THAT REPRESENTS
DOCTOR. INSIDE CDCR HAS BEEN
VERY ADAMANT ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SALARY INCREASES FOR THE CIVIL
SERVICE STAFF AT èC Dð èC R,
UH, THEY WERE CLOSE TO GOING ON
STRIKE IN THE FALL, BUT
ULTIMATELY CAME TO AN AGREEMENT.
UM, I WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT MORE. IN REGARDS TO,
UH WHAT PERCENTAGE DO YOU GUYS
UTILIZE FOR INTERNAL STAFF? FULL
TIME. UH, F Tð E S¼ VERSUS UH,
CONTRACTED OUTWORK. I. I THINK
THAT IS ANOTHER ONE THAT WE'LL
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP ON. UM BETWEEN
THE NUMBER OF F Tð E S¼, UM IN
THE CONTRACT REGISTRY COVERAGE,
OK, AND THE REASON WHY I
HIGHLIGHT THIS IS BECAUSE ANY
TYPE OF OVERTIME COSTS OR
POTENTIAL CONTRACTING OUT MAY
POTENTIALLY RESULT IN HIGHER
COSTS OVERALL, IF WE DON'T FILL
UP THOSE SPOTS, SO, UM, HEALTH
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ALL
INMATES. IT'S A HUMAN, RIGHT IN
MY OPINION. UM SO, I. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
ANSWERS THAT WE NEED IN TO THIS.
UM AND THEN I HAVE ONE FINAL
QUESTION IF THIS REQUEST WERE
APPROVED, AND THE DEPARTMENT NÓ
LONGER HAD TO ABSORB THE COST,
WHAT WOULD THE NEWLY FREED UP
MONEY BE USED FOR? UM THE
FUNDING HAS BEEN REDIRECTED FROM
OUR MENTAL HEALTH BUDGET
PRIMARILY AND THAT MONEY IS FOR
SALARY AND WAGES TO HIGHER
MENTAL HEALTH. UM WE HAVE BEEN
DILIGENTLY TRYING TO FILL ALL
THOSE MENTAL HEALTH VACANCIES
AND SO THAT MONEY WOULD GO BACK
TO MENTAL HEALTH TO, YOU KNOW,
COVER THEIR THEIR STAFFING NEEDS
, UM AS A HIGHER UP, OK AND THEN
IF WE WERE TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN REGARDS
TO TELEHEALTH AND UTILIZE THAT
OPTION MORE, WHICH IS BEING
WIDELY UTILIZED, UM THEY'RE ALL
ALSO MAY BE, UH, NÓ NEED FOR ANY
SECURITY PAY, CONSIDERING IT'S
DONE ONLINE. SO I, I DO WANNA
HIGHLIGHT THAT AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT SO, UH, ELIMINATING AS MUCH
COST THAT'S UNNECESSARY AS
POSSIBLE. UM, SO DO I HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM NÓ? ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM.
I APPRECIATE YOUR OK, THANK
THANK YOU. NUMBER SIX IS
COVID-19 PROPOSALS. YES. SO.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN. WE'LL BE
HEARING FROM èC Dð èC R FIRST
AND WE WILL TIME YOU AGAIN AT
FIVE MINUTES. OK UM, SO THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING 38.4
MILLION FOR ONGOING COVID
MITIGATION. UM WE HAVE CONTINUED
TO SEE COVID WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS AND WE HAVE AN
ONGOING NEED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. UM MUCH OF THE FUNDING IS
TIED AROUND EMPLOYEE TESTING AND
TESTING FOR OUR INCARCERATED
PERSONS, UM, AS WELL AS PP
EQUIPMENT AND VACCINES. SO THE
FUNDING FOR THIS YEAR WE STARTED
WITH AN 80 THREE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET. UM WE'VE CURRENTLY TAKEN
THAT DOWN TO 50 THREE MILLION
AND AS MORE CURRENT PROJECTIONS
COME IN, UM, THAT WILL BE
ADJUSTED AS NECESSARY IF
NECESSARY, BUT WE FEEL 38
MILLION IS OUR BUDGET, YOUR NEED
AND ONGOING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
. THE FUNDING IS IN IN, UH WHEN
ISOLATED BUDGET, SO IT'S ONLY
FOR COVID EXPENDITURES IS NOT
FOR ANY OTHER EXPENDITURES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. SO IN THE
EVENT, UM IT IS NOT NEEDED FOR
COVID. IT WOULD RETURN TO THE
GENERAL FUND. ALL RIGHT. CAN WE
GET L A Ó S¼ RESPONSE. ORLANDO
AGAIN WITH THE L A Ó. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL
AND DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO
UPDATE ITS REQUEST FOR 2425 TO
REFLECT MORE RECENT DATA. UH, IN
DOING SO, THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
USE A STANDARD A SNAPSHOT OF
MONTHS WHEN CALCULATING ITS NEED
FOR EACH OF THE ACTIVITIES. IT'S
REQUESTING RESOURCES FOR AND IN
THOSE MONTHS PROVIDED
JUSTIFICATION. WHY THOSE
SPECIFIC SELECTED MONTHS? UM OR
PROVIDE JUSTIFICATION ON WHY
THOSE MAKE THE MOST SENSE TO BE
BUDGETED FOR. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD ACCOUNT FOR,
UH, THE PRISON POPULATION
UPDATES, UM AND LIKELY TO COME
IN THE SPRING, AND THEN WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT TO EXPLORE
OPTIONS. UH, TO LEVERAGE THE
STATE, UH, EMPLOYER SPONSORED
HEALTH INSURANCE THAT WOULD
LIKELY RE REDUCE THE EMPLOYEE
VACCINE COSTS THAT ARE BUDGETED
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL. THESE
ADJUSTMENTS WOULD LIKELY REDUCE
THE OVERALL COST. UP GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES. UH AND FINALLY,
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE FUNDING PROPOSED FOR
THE FUTURE AND CONTINUE TO FUND
UH, COVID-19 ON A ONE TIME
BASIS, AS HAS BEEN DONE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS. THANK YOU. AND
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RESPONSE. HØI THERE. UM, ONGOING
COVID-19 FUNDS WILL BE USED NOT
ONLY TO ADDRESS CURRENT COVID
CASES, UM, BUT ALSO TO MAINTAIN
A STATE OF READINESS TO ASSIST
WITH MAKING SURE CALIFORNIA IS
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE
PROTECTED. UM THIS REQUEST IS
BASED ON CURRENT YOUR ACTUALS,
UH, THAT WERE FROM THE MOST
RECENT DATA OF A AVAILABLE WHEN
THE PROPOSAL WAS PUT FORTH. UM
THE USE OF THIS DATA SET WAS
INTENTIONAL TO CAPTURE THE MOST
LIKELY EXPENDITURE NEEDS HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. UM, WOULD YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS? NÓ. WE HAVE
NOTHING ELSE TO ADD. ALL RIGHT?
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE? I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT IT. IT JUST SEEMS
A LITTLE COUNTER INTUITIVE IN
THE SENSE THAT THE STATE PAYS
FOR INSURANCE FOR THE STAFF
ALREADY, UM MOST, UH, EMPLOYEES,
I'M I'M VERY MUCH SURE THAT THEY
ARE INSURED CURRENTLY, RIGHT?
YES CORRECT. OK SO WHY ARE WE
ALSO PAYING FOR THINGS COVERED
BY THAT INSURANCE? FOR EXAMPLE,
STAFF VACCINATIONS. UM WE DO IT?
UH UM AS A CONVENIENCE TO THE
EMPLOYEES. UM UNFORTUNATELY,
WE'RE NOT A BILLING DEPARTMENT
SO WE CAN'T UM FURTHER, BILL.
UM, PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCES,
UM, ON BEHALF OF THE EMPLOYEE,
AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
KOSHA REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE
THOSE VACCINE AVAILABLE, UM, TO
OUR EMPLOYEES WHO WORK IN THE,
UH, YOU KNOW, IN THE HEALTHCARE
AREAS, SO AS AN EMPLOYER, IT'S
WE ARE REQUIRED TO OFFER THOSE
VACCINES IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND DO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE? UM GOT COVID OVER
THE COURSE OF YOU KNOW, SINCE
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH COVID
CAREER. UM, WITH ME TODAY, ONE
SECOND. WITH ME TODAY IS DEBORAH
AMOS TERRELL, WHO IS OVER OUR
EMPLOYEE HEALTH PROGRAM, AND SHE
MAY BE ABLE TO ARTICULATE THIS,
UH, A LITTLE BETTER THAN MYSELF.
I'M ASSUMING IT'S GOING DOWN.
YES MONITORING OUR STAFF. I I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE WANTING TO KNOW
THE STAFFER. YES WE STOPPED
MONITORING THAT ABOUT A YEAR AGO
. BUT WE CERTAINLY CAN GIVE YOU
THE DATA UP TO THAT POINT. BUT
YEAH, WE AND ALSO, UM IN THE
PRIOR YEARS BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH,
YOU KNOW A RISK. UH THE STAFF
ARE REQUIRED TO, UM, REPORT IF
THEY WERE POSITIVE AND DO ALL
THESE THINGS AND WE WOULD FOLLOW
THEM, AND WE WOULD KNOW YOU
KNOW, IN TERMS OF THEIR VACCINE
STATUS. UH, PARTICULARLY AS YOU
KNOW, èC, Dð èC AND èC Dð P
HÌ CHANGED THE REQUIREMENT. SO
UM, I WOULD IMAGINE. YES IT'S
GONE DOWN. UM, BUT WE CAN GIVE
YOU THAT DATA FROM A YEAR AGO.
OK, I. I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE DON'T WANT ANY
DUPLICATIVE SERVICES, UM, AND
SPENDING UH AND WE DO OBVIOUSLY
SEE THAT JUST FROM YOU KNOW THIS
, UH, FOR THE INDIVIDUALS HELD
IN THESE, UH, FACILITIES. OF
COURSE. YOU KNOW, WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE PRIORITIZE HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH AND SO FORTH.
UM SO I APPRECIATE THAT, UM, I
ALSO IF YOU DO SHARE ANY DATA
WITH US, UM, I ALSO WANT TO SEE
HOW MANY VACCINES ARE GOING TO
STAFF VERSUS THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. UM WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, WHICH IS
EMPLOYEE HEALTH PROGRAM
REDUCTION WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
èC Dð èC R AGAIN TIMING YOU AT
FIVE MINUTES, OK? UM THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. UM WE ARE ACTUALLY
ASKING FOR A REDUCTION OF 7.1
MILLION IN THIS PROPOSAL AND TO
REDUCE ROUGHLY 40 STAFF, UM,
TIED TO OUR EMPLOYEE HEALTH
PROGRAM. UM WITH ME TODAY IS
DEBORAH S¼ TERRELL AS I
MENTIONED, AND SHE HAS A
STATEMENT REGARDING THIS GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. UM DEBORAH MS
TORELL, THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR NURSING FOR èC, HÌ
èC S¼. UM, THE EMPLOYEE HEALTH
PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE
TRANSMISSION OF COVID-19 AND
OTHER AEROSOL TRANSMISSIBLE
DISEASES AMONG STAFF, REFLECTING
A PROACTIVE APPROACH TOWARD
ENHANCING WORKPLACE HEALTH AND
SAFETY, THE PROGRAM'S EXPANSION
TO COVER A BROADER SPECTRUM OF
AT Tð Dð S¼, SUCH AS
TUBERCULOSIS ALONGSIDE THE
INITIAL COVID-19 FOCUS OCCURRED
IN 2023 AND REPRESENTED A
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO MANAGE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES, WHICH
ARE HIGH RISK ENVIRONMENTS FOR
THE TRANSMISSION OF A Tð Dð S¼,
THE PROGRAM ACHIEVE EFFICIENCIES
THROUGH THE INTEGRATION OF
ANALYTICAL TOOLS, UH FOR
OUTBREAK MANAGEMENT, PUBLIC
HEALTH TRACKING INFECTIOUS
DISEASE INVESTIGATIONS AND
STREAMLINE THE COVID-19
NOTIFICATIONS. THIS
TECHNOLOGICAL APPROACH ALLOWED
FOR A MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE WITHIN THE
èC Dð èC R SYSTEM. FURTHERMORE
BY NARROWING THE PROGRAMMATIC
SCOPE TO ALIGN, UM, THE PROGRAM
EXCLUSIVELY WITH CALL OSHA'S A
Tð Dð S¼, UM AND THE E HÌ P HAS
SHARPENED ITS FOCUS ON MOST
PRESSING HEALTH RISK ENSURING
COMPLIANCE AND MITIGATING THE
SPREAD OF A Tð, Dð S¼ AND
CORRECTIONAL SETTINGS. THE
IMPACT OF THE E HÌ P IS EVIDENT
IN THE SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS
IN COMPLIANCE RATES FOR
INFLUENZA AND Tð AND Tð B
COMPLIANCE. REACHING UM 60 THREE
TO 96.7% RESPECTIVELY IN 2023,
THE  N NOTABLE INCREASE IN
COMPLIANCE ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF OVER 1000
VACCINES AND PROCESSING MORE
THAN 10,000 INFLUENZA. DONATIONS
HIGHLIGHTS THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS IN ENGAGING STAFF
AND INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS IN
HEALTH PROMOTION AND HEALTH
PROTECTION MEASURES. THE
REDUCTION IN COVID-19 CASES AND
CLOSE CONTACTS BY APPROXIMATELY
50% ALONGSIDE THE MANAGEMENT OF
NUMEROUS CASE INVESTIGATION AND
TRACING EVENTS AND INSTITUTIONAL
OUTBREAKS FURTHER DEMONSTRATE TO
E HÌ P'S ROLE IN CONTROLLING THE
SPREAD OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE
WITHIN THE èC Dð èC R. SO A
SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT OF THE A
P IS THE ELIMINATION OF
CITATIONS AND FINES RELATED TO A
Dð VIOLATIONS IN 2020 THREE, A
STARK CONTRAST TO PREVIOUS YEARS
, THE REDUCTION IN CITATIONS
RELATED TO FIT TESTING TIMELY
NOTIFICATION OF EXPOSURES TO
STAFF, MEDICAL EVALUATIONS AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN A Tð Dð
PLAN DEMONSTRATES THE PROGRAMS,
ABILITY TO MEET REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND ENHANCING
EMPLOYEE HEALTH PROTECTIONS. SO
IN CONCLUSION, THE EFFICIENCIES
FOUND AND THE SUBSEQUENT
NARROWING OF THE PROGRAM FOCUS
HAVE RESULTED IN A MORE TARGETED
AND EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
MANAGING HEALTH RISKS WITHIN èC
, Dð èC R, AND THUS A, UM
REFLECTS A REQUEST FOR US TO
DECREASING OUR STAFFING
ALLOCATION. THE E HÌ P SUCCESS
IS A TESTAMENT TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF UTILIZING ANALYTICAL TOOLS,
ENHANCING STAFF, KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPLIANCE STATEWIDE AND
ADHERING TO STATE, UH,
REGULATORY STANDARDS TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH OF THE
STAFF. THANK YOU, L, A Ó. WE
DON'T RAISE CONCERNS WITH THIS
PRODUCTION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ
CONCERNS. SO UM, I SPECIFICALLY
JUST WANT TO SAY THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN DOWNSIZED MULTIPLE
TIMES. SO WHAT EFFICIENCIES WERE
FOUND TO ENABLE THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION AND HOW DO THEY AFFECT
THE OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM?
SO, YEAH, IT HAS TO TRUST ME. I
KNOW IT'S BEEN DOWNSIZED MANY,
MANY TIMES. AND SO AS THE, UM
MANAGER OF THE PROGRAM, AND
BECAUSE OF OUR FISCAL ISSUES,
UH, WE LOOKED AT THE PROGRAM AND
WE BASICALLY SAID OK, UM, IN
TERMS OF WHEN WE GOT RID OF OUR
ANALYTICAL STAFF, WE TOOK THAT
THOSE FUNCTIONS AND UP TO THE
HEADQUARTERS LEVELS TO GET ALL
TO DO THOSE FUNCTIONS. WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THE CLINICAL PIECES.
UM, WE USED TO HAVE A MA. WE
USED TO HAVE AN ALVIAN. SO WHEN
WE HAD TO DOWNSIZE BEFORE WE
SAID, WELL, THE, UH THE R  N IS,
UM, ABLE TO ENCUMBER ALL OF
THOSE TASK AND THOSE FUNCTIONS.
AND SO NOW WE ARE DECREASING
FROM TO OUR ENDS TO ONE OUR END.
WILL IT BE A CONCERN IN TERMS OF
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE STAFF?
BECAUSE WE WON'T HAVE SEVEN DAY
COVERAGE? WE'LL HAVE FIVE. YES
BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS, IN TERMS
OF, YOU KNOW, BEING FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE. OK, AND THEN WHY
NOT JUST ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM?
UM WELL, I THINK THAT WOULD BE,
UM, A BAD DECISION BECAUSE WE
ARE REQUIRED RIGHT TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH KOSHA STANDARDS.
E HÌ P IS WHAT IS KEEPING èC Dð
èC R IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
STANDARDS. WE DIDN'T HAVE A
DEFINED PROGRAM UP UNTIL 2020
BEFORE THAT WE ALMOST HAD IN
THAT. PROBABLY PRIOR THREE OR
FOUR YEARS SPAN ALMOST A MILLION
DOLLARS IN FINES. AND AS I
STATED BEFORE, IN 2023, WE HAVE
NÓ A Tð Dð FINES. RIGHT AND THEN
THE MAJORITY OF YOUR WORKFORCE.
UH, WHAT DOES THEIR SCHEDULE
LOOK LIKE? SO THE MAJORITY OF
THE WORKFORCE? UH, THEY WORK 10.
WELL THEY DO SHERRY 10 OR 8 1010
HOURS A DAY. OKAY, SO IT'S LIKE,
FOUR TENS? YES. FOUR TENS.
ALRIGHT UM AND HAVE YOU GUYS
TAKEN A LOOK AT HOW, UH,
POTENTIAL R  N IS ABLE TO KIND
OF POTENTIALLY REDUCE THEIR
HOURS AND FOCUS ON THE COVERAGE?
YEAH, WE LOOKED AT, UM, MAYBE
DOING 58. BUT AGAIN, UH, RIGHT
NOW WE STILL HAVE THOSE STAFF.
SO WE'RE DOING THE FOUR TENS TO
COVER THE SEVEN. SO ABSOLUTELY,
IF YOU KNOW THE, UM IF WE'RE, UH
. IF THIS IS APPROVED THE
DOWNSIZING YES, WE WILL DO FOR
85 DAY, EIGHT HOUR COVERAGE. YOU
GUYS HAVE THE OPTION OF THREE
TWELVES. NÓ ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
. UM NÓ FURTHER COMMENTS, ALL
RIGHT, WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM. ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT.
THIS IS OUR FINAL ITEM COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAM FUNDING
ADJUSTMENT. SORRY. ONE MORE
ITEM. WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM èC
Dð èC R AGAIN. FIVE MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN. JUST NATO
AND ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
BUDGET MANAGEMENT BRANCH. UH,
THIS REQUEST IS FOR 2.3 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN 2425 INCREASING
TO 3.4 MILLION IN 28 28 29 TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR PAROLEE
COMMUNITY RANCHER PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY DAY REPORTING
CENTERS AND THE LONG TERM
OFFENDER REENTRY AND RECOVERY
PROGRAM, UM, TO SUPPORT CON
CONTINUITY OF SERVICES. UM TO
THE PAROLEE POPULATION WITH ME
IS NICKY DILLON, THE DIVISION
DIRECTOR OF THE, UH VISION
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM SUPPORT OF
THE DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU, L A Ó. CONCERNS AT
THIS TIME WITH THIS PROPOSAL,
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL? UM
ALL RIGHT. I JUST WANTED TO ASK
WHICH OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENT. HOW MUCH OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT ARE WE DRAWING
DOWN AND ARE THERE AREAS IN
WHICH WE COULD BE DRAWING DOWN
MORE REIMBURSEMENTS? UM GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON OUR PROGRAMS. UM
SO OUR REENTRY FACILITIES ARE
MALE COMMUNITY REENTRY
FACILITIES IN OUR FEMALE
COMMUNITY. REENTRY FACILITIES.
UM INDIVIDUALS IN PHASE THREE OF
THAT PROGRAM. IT'S A FOUR PHASE
PROGRAM. THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO,
UM, LEVERAGE MEDICAL SERVICES.
SO WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL GOES TO
THAT PROGRAM IN PHASE ONE, THEY
SHOULD BE APPLYING FOR ME SO
THAT WHEN THEY REACH PHASE
THREE, THEY CAN LEVERAGE THOSE
SERVICES. UM. WOULD HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THE AMOUNT OF,
UM, FUNDING THAT, UM, FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT FOR LEVERAGING
THANK YOU. AND HOW DOES èC Dð
èC R VET AND OVERSEE THE
OPERATORS OF THESE PROGRAMS AND,
UM, EVALUATE WHICH PROGRAMS
PRODUCE THE BEST RESULTS? UM SO
AS FAR AS CONTRACT COMPLIANCE,
UM, STAFF HAVE A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES TO, UM, OVERSEE. UH,
THEY THERE. OUR COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS ARE A VARIETY. UM
THERE'S A NETWORK. UM THE AGENDA
DOES A NICE JOB OF LAYING OUT
OUR PROGRAMS. BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE ARE SUBCONTRACTORS.
THERE ARE OVER 700
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT, UM, THE
CONTRACTORS THAT WE, UH,
CONTRACT WITH DIRECTLY, UM, MUST
OVERSEE AND THOSE SUBCONTRACTORS
ARE CHANGING, SO THEY NEED TO
LOOK AT THE STAFFING MAKING SURE
THAT, UM THEY HAVE. THEY'RE
HIRING THE RIGHT STAFF. THEY
NEED TO LOOK AT, UM ALL OF THE
LICENSES AND REQUIREMENTS THAT
NOW CAN BE UPLOADED INTO CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. UM THERE'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO. AND, UM WE CAN DO BETTER.
WE ARE TRYING TO USE TECHNOLOGY
TO AUTOMATE SOME THINGS TO HAVE
PROVIDERS PUT INFORMATION INTO
OUR CASE MANAGEMENT. YOU HAVE
700 SUBCONTRACTORS.
APPROXIMATELY WELL, NOT FOR THE
NOT FOR THESE 12. I WAS THINKING
OUR WHOLE PRO PROGRAMS, UM,
INCLUDING OUR, UM, SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM. SO YEAH,
THERE'S A LARGE SUBCONTRACTOR,
SO OVERSIGHT OF 700 POTENTIAL
SUBCONTRACTORS IS A BIG TASK.
CORRECT AND SO WITHIN OUR, UH,
CONTRACT WITH OUR, UM DIRECT
CONTRACTORS, THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO, UM DO, UH, A PROGRAM
ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT FOR THOSE
SUBCONTRACTORS, AND NOW THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO UPLOAD THOSE INTO
OUR CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND
STAFF ARE ABLE TO RUN REPORTS
TO, UM, MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THOSE DONE. YOU AUDIT.
SO I'M IN 2020 THREE. THE TEAM
IS GOING OUT AND DOING IN PERSON
AUDITS OF OUR DIRECT, UH,
CONTRACTORS AND THE GOAL IS TO
DO ABOUT 10% OF OUR
SUBCONTRACTORS. AND WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE COST PER CONTRACT?
AVERAGE COST PER CONTRACT. I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT ONE. ALL RIGHT? WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THIS AGAIN, ESPECIALLY
FOR REENTRY PROGRAMS. I. I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME UNIFORMITY AND FOCUS ON
TRUE REENTRY. UM EFFORTS IF YOU
WILL, FROM HEALTHCARE TO, UM.
YOU KNOW, SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO JOB
PLACEMENT TO XY AND Z. BUT AGAIN
, I THINK THAT VERY DIFFICULT TO
HAVE A CLEAR STANDARD ACROSS ALL
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS.
SO UM, JUST PRIORITIZING THAT,
UH, IN FUTURE CONVERSATIONS UM
AND SENATOR DE RAZA THANK YOU
ALONG THOSE LINES. OF COURSE, I
TOTALLY SUPPORT ALL THE PRE. UH
UH. AND POST. UH, RELEASE, UH,
PROGRAMS. I THINK THEY'RE
EXTRAORDINARY BUT SOMEWHAT ALONG
THE LINES OF WHAT THE CHAIR SAID
IS, WHAT ARE HOW DO YOU
DETERMINE? AND WHERE IS IT
CENTRALIZED. TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THIS IS A KIND OF PRE OR POST
RELEASE PROGRAM WE NEED HERE IN
THIS, UH, PRISON OR IN ANOTHER
ONE. HOW DO YOU COME UP WITH?
YOU KNOW, UH UH, A MORE. UH UH,
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION OF WHAT?
ALL THOSE PRO PROGRAMS DO. I'VE
BEEN THROUGH A NUMBER OF PRISONS
. I'VE BEEN TO A NUMBER OF POST
RELEASE, UH, PROGRAMS AND SOME
ARE REALLY GREAT. I DON'T KNOW
ALL OF THEM, BUT I DON'T KNOW,
CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW WHERE
ANYWHERE NEAR ABOUT THE 700
PROGRAMS, BUT IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE OUT THERE THEY APPLY,
AND AS LONG AS THEY DO WHAT THAT
PARTICULAR CONTRACT REQUIRES OF
THEM, THEN THAT'S COOL, RIGHT?
THEY THEY PASS. BUT THAT DOESN'T
TELL ME WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH ALL THE
PROGRAMS TOGETHER, SO IF THERE'S
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT CENTRALIZED, UH MORE
THAN AND I DON'T WANNA TAKE
AWAY. THE ABILITY OF THE PRISONS
TO DECIDE THE WARDENS TO DECIDE.
THIS PROGRAM FITS BETTER THAN
THAT PROGRAM, BUT IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE HUNDREDS OUT THERE, BUT NOT
REALLY KNOWING WHAT THE RESULTS
ARE AND WHAT WE'RE GOING
TOWARDS. YES. SO FOR OUR, UM,
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAMS, UH,
THE AGENDA DID MENTION THE
STANFORD STUDY THAT SHOWED
REALLY GOOD OUTCOMES FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION, WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE OF
RESEARCH TO ALSO LOOK AT
RECIDIVISM FOR OUR COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS. SO, I, I I'M GONNA
RELATE THIS, UM TO HOMELESSNESS
IN THE CITY THAT I WAS A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN AND OF COURSE,
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVICE
THE, UH, UNHOUSED POPULATION.
UH, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE AND MAYBE YOU
ALREADY HAVE IT, BUT I WOULD
LOVE SOME SOME DATA OR SOME
FEEDBACK IS THAT IF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE TAKING PLACE, UM
THERE HAS TO BE A STANDARD OF
LIKE, OK. WHAT DO YOU DO YOU,
UH, YOU KNOW, ATTAIN TO GRADUATE
. LET'S SAY THE PROGRAM COMPLETE
THE PROGRAM OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT. BUT THEN A YEAR FOLLOW UP.
IF THERE IS ANY RECORDS THAT WE
KIND OF SEE IS LIKE ONE. HAVE
THEY KEPT A JOB, HAVE THEY? YOU
KNOW, UH, OBVIOUSLY BEEN A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY OR
ARE THEY IN SCHOOL? SOME OF
THESE METRICS THAT WE NEED TO
SEE IT'S NOT JUST GETTING OUT OF
THE PROGRAM, BUT IT'S LIKE LONG
TERM SUPPORT FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT'S WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SEE. RIGHT AND WHEN
WE'VE INITIATED THIS IN OUR
LOCAL CITY REGARDING OBVIOUSLY
THE UNHOUSED POPULATION, UH, WE
SAW SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS AND
ALSO MORE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. SO MY TWO CENTS.
UH, I DO APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
TIME. MY FINAL QUESTION IS. HOW
DID THE ADMINISTRATION LAND ON
THE PROPOSED FUNDING
METHODOLOGY? UM, SO WHAT WE DID
WAS WE LOOKED AT, UM FROM THE
CONTRACT. UH, INCEPTION. THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX OVER THE
YEARS AND SOME THAT TO THEN GIVE
THAT A TRUE UP. FOR THIS FOR, UH
, BUDGET YEAR AND THEN 2%
ONGOING. WE FEEL LIKE THAT'S AAA
GOOD BALANCE OF, UM, PROVIDING
YOU KNOW THE INCREASED COSTS
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY
AS WELL AS BEING FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE IN THIS BUDGET
CLIMATE. ALL RIGHT, I APPRECIATE
IT. UH, WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE INCREASED
ATTORNEY FEES FOR BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS. WE'LL HEAR
FIRST FROM èC Dð èC R. WE'LL
TIME YOU AT FIVE MINUTES. THANK
YOU. CDCR REQUEST 2.1 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN 2425 AND ONGOING
TO MAINTAIN UPDATED FUNDING FOR
FEES PAID TO ATTORNEYS WHO
REPRESENT THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION AT PAROLE HEARINGS
WITH ME IS JENNIFER SHAFER, THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS. IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS, THANK YOU, L A
Ó. DIDN'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING. UH
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS? UH,
FROM THIS COMMITTEE. ALRIGHT UM,
I. I SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW DOES THE BOARD
ENSURE THAT THE APPOINTED
ATTORNEYS FULFILL THEIR
OBLIGATIONS, INCLUDING THE
REQUIRED EXTRA HOUR OF COUNSEL?
SO WE HAVE AN INVOICE PROCESS,
SO THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY
DESIGNATE THE DATE AND WHEN THEY
MET WITH THEIR CLIENT AND FOR
HOW LONG THEY MET, AND WE
ROUTINELY AUDIT THOSE, UM WITH
VISITATION RECORDS FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS, WE ALSO HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH A NONPROFIT THIRD
PARTY, UH, INDEPENDENT ENTITY
WHO PROVIDES, UM SOME MONITORING
AND OBSERVATION, AND THEY ALSO
SURVEY THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION. WE ACTUALLY THE
BOARD IS REQUIRED TO SEND OUT A
TRANSCRIPT. OF THE PAROLE
HEARING ONCE IT'S CONCLUDED TO
THE INCARCERATED PERSON WITH
THAT TRANSCRIPT, WE SEND A
SURVEY WITH A SELF ADDRESSED,
STAMPED ENVELOPE TO PAROLE.
JUSTICE WORKS, THE NONPROFIT
THIRD PARTY AND IT'S A SURVEY
ABOUT THEIR, UM, SATISFACTION OR
THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH THEIR
CLIENT WITH THEIR ATTORNEY, AND
THAT GOES TO PAROLE. JUSTICE
WORKS NOT TO THE BOARD AND THEY
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION TO US. TOUCHED
A COUPLE POINTS. I WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE BOARD ENSURES
THAT THE APPOINTED ATTORNEYS ARE
SUFFICIENTLY INDEPENDENT FROM
THE BOARD ITSELF, UM, IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO FULLY REPRESENT
THEIR CLIENTS AND BOARD
PROCEEDINGS, SO WE APPOINT
COUNSEL AND WE PAY COUNSEL AND
WE OBVIOUSLY USING THOSE
INVOICES IS HOW WE PAY THOSE
COUNCILS. BUT PALE JUSTICE WORKS
AS THE INDEPENDENT ENTITY THAT
ACTUALLY PROVIDES TRAINING,
MENTORSHIP AND OVERSIGHT OF
THEIR PERFORMANCE AND FEEDS THAT
INFORMATION BACK TO US. OK BUT
YOU ALSO PAY THE NONPROFIT
CORRECT. WE DO. UM HAS THE BOARD
EXPLORED PAY STRUCTURES OTHER
THAN A FLAT FEE? WE DID LONG AGO
WE HAD A STRUCTURED FEE WHERE IF
THEY WENT LET'S SAY THEY, UM.
THEY READ THE CENTRAL FILE, AND
THEY MET WITH THEIR CLIENT ONCE
THEY WOULD GET A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF MONEY. AND THEN, AS THE CASE
PROGRESSED, THEY WOULD GET MORE
AND MORE MONEY. UM WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT ACTUALLY CREATED A
REVERSE INCENTIVE FOR EVERYONE
TO GO TO HEARING EVEN IF THEY
WERE NOT SUITABLE FOR PAROLE,
AND SO WE TURNED TO A FLAT RATE
FEE INSTEAD, BECAUSE WHAT IT
ALLOWS IS SOME CASES ARE GONNA
TAKE MORE HOURS THAN OTHER CASES
AND BUT THEY GET A WEEK'S WORTH
OF ASSIGNMENTS, SO THEY'LL BE
ASSIGNED TO EVERY PERSON WHO HAS
A HEARING AT A PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION DURING A ONE WEEK
PERIOD, AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
NOT GONNA GO FORWARD AND SO
GETTING A FLAT RATE NUMBER ONE.
IT ENSURES THEIR INCOME. IT
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT MORE, UM,
STABLE, AND IT ALLOWS FOR THEM
TO SPEND MORE TIME ON THE MORE
COMPLEX CASES THAT ARE GOING TO
GO TO HEARING VERSUS THE ONES
THAT ARE NOT. THANK YOU, UM THE
LAL. A Ó REPORT FROM LAST YEAR
HAD A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR IMPROVING EQUITY IN THE
PAROLE PROCESS. DID THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER ANY OF
THOSE OPTIONS? WE WENT THROUGH
AND LOOKED AT ALL OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. UM, WE ARE
ENGAGED IN A RESEARCH A MORE IN
DEPTH RESEARCH PROJECT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
BERKELEY. UM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE, AND,
UH, WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THE
RESULTS OF THAT. I'LL SAY ONE OF
THE IS THAT, UM I PERSONALLY AM
MUCH MORE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THAT IT BE A MEANINGFUL ANALYSIS
, MEANING WE KNOW FOR ABOUT 20
YEARS, FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGY HAS
BEEN PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
ABOUT WHAT INCREASES OR MITIGATE
SOMEBODY'S RISK. AND WE WOULD
LIKE FOR A MEANINGFUL REVIEW
BASED THAT CONTROLS FOR THOSE
RISK BASED FACTORS. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY IS INTENDING
TO DO. UM AND I WILL SAY THIS IN
REGARDS TO INDEPENDENCE OF, UM,
INPUT. UH, SPECIFICALLY, OTHER
MODELS HAVE SHOWN THAT I'M GOING
TO GIVE THE NORWAY MODEL UH,
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HANDLES EDUCATION
CONCERNS FOR, UH, INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
HANDLES. UH, HEALTH CONCERNS. UM
AND OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE. WE CAN
GO DEEPER. BUT THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE. UM HAS THE
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT ABOUT
POTENTIALLY LETTING GO OF SOME
OF THE RE THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
ALLOWING OTHER, UH, INSTITUTIONS
TO STEP IN. TO DO THE APPOINTED
COUNSEL. YOU MEAN APPOINTED
COUNSEL OR HEALTH OR EDUCATION
OR ANY OF THESE OTHER PIECES? I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR èC Dð èC R ON
SOME OF THOSE OTHER PIECES, BUT
FOR BP HÌ I, I WILL SAY THAT WE
DO WORK WITH OTHER INDIVIDUAL
ENTITIES THAT SPECIFICALLY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FROM
WE'RE EXPLORING AS PART OF KING,
UM, TO HAVE IN REACH INTO THE
PRISON FOR HEALTHCARE SERVICES
COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT. I'M NOT
SURE WHAT YOU MEAN BY
INDEPENDENT, I GUESS, UM,
SPECIFICALLY, FOR EXAMPLE, EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT IS GEARED
TOWARDS LET'S SAY EDUCATION IS
HANDLED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH, THAT THE
THERAPIST UM ARE NOT NECESSARILY
PAID OR WORK FOR èC Dð èC R
BUT ARE COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT
AND REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. I. I GUESS
IT WOULD KIND OF DEPEND ON THE
INDIVIDUAL POSITION. I KNOW WITH
EDUCATION FOR AN EXAMPLE, SOME
OF THE COLLEGE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSES ARE, YOU KNOW,
RUN BY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THOSE, AND THE REASON WHY I
HIGHLIGHT THIS IS BECAUSE, UM,
SPECIFICALLY, YOU KNOW, DOING
THESE TOURS OF THE PRISONS AND
SPEAKING TO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED, THEY OFTEN FEEL
THAT THEY CANNOT, YOU KNOW,
ATTEND SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE, UH, EVERYONE IN THE
INSTITUTION WILL KNOW THE GUARDS
WILL KNOW. AND THERE'S NÓ
PRIVACY. UM SO ENSURING THAT IF
SOMEBODY IS WORKING ON
THEMSELVES REALLY COMMITTED TO
THAT, UM, THEY SHOULD HAVE SOME
AUTONOMY, SOME PRIVACY AND SOME
BASIC STANDARDS. UM AND I. I
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S
BEEN ANY EFFORT IN SOME OF THESE
THINGS. AGAIN I. I THINK IT
WOULD BE CASE BY CASE BASIS ON
THOSE INDIVIDUAL INITIATIVES.
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT ANY LARGE
SCALE STATEWIDE INITIATIVE,
THOUGH I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT THAT IN PARTICULAR. UM IF
WE HAVE NÓ FURTHER COMMENTS, UH,
WE ARE HAPPY TO CLOSE. UM, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. UH, WE ARE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS A
CHANCE TO BE HEARD. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO 30 SECONDS OR
LET'S SAY A MINUTE. UM DEPENDING
ON THE LENGTH OF THE LINE, AND
IF SOME SOMEONE ELSE HAS ALREADY
, UH, MADE SIMILAR COMMENTS,
PLEASE JUST STATE. ME TOO. UM,
THANK YOU, AND LET'S BEGIN. HØI
MY NAME'S DARBY KERNAN. I
REPRESENT AND WE'RE GOING WITH
30 MINUTES AND 30 SECONDS.
SORRY. GOT YOU. I GET ANOTHER
FIVE SECONDS. ALL RIGHT. GO
AHEAD. OK UH, DARBY KERNAN. I
REPRESENT THE NONPROFIT UH,
REENTRY PROVIDERS. WECARE HEALTH
RATE THREE 60 AMITY FOUNDATION.
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. BUDGET PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, DANICA ROAR,
ALL COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE ON BEHALF OF ROOT AND
REBOUND AND INITIATE JUSTICE WHO
ARE MEMBERS OF THE GATE MONEY
COALITION, UH, REQUESTING THAT
IF THE TRANS METRO PROGRAM IS
ELIMINATED THAT MONEY BE REAL,
LOCATED TO BENEFIT THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION, THEIR
LOVED ONES, POTENTIALLY BY
ENDING THE PRACTICE OF REMOVING
MONEY FROM PEOPLE'S GATE
ALLOWANCE OF $200 FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND CLOTHING. UM
ALSO COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO AND THREE ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE SUPPORTING THE
PLAN. PRISON CLOSURES, UM,
ENCOURAGING MORE PRISON CLOSURES
AND OPPOSING THE REALLOCATION OF
FUNDS FOR THE CALIFORNIA BASED
REALITY TRAINING FACILITY. THANK
YOU. NEXT. HØI GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH. ASK ME, CALIFORNIA. I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
PRISON CLOSURES. UM I HOPE THAT
AS THIS CAN THIS DISCUSSION
MOVES FORWARD THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH CAUTION. SOME
FACILITIES ARE INTEGRAL PART OF
THE LOCAL ECONOMY FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES, UH, IN THESE
FACILITIES PROVIDE WELL PAYING
JOBS IN A CORNER OF THE STATE,
WHERE WELL PAYING JOBS ARE HARD
TO FIND. UH, MEMBERS ARE WITH
MERIT. WE WORRIED ABOUT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ON CLOSERS, AND SO
WHEN THESE AS WE NAIL DOWN, UH,
WHAT FACILITIES ARE BEING CLOSED
? UH, WE HOPE THAT WE CAN CORE,
UM, ALONG WITH OTHER LABOR
UNIONS, UH, IN THESE FACILITIES
ARE JUST TRANSITION. UM ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS ON RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT OF THE WORKFORCE. WE
NEED TO MAKE A SERIOUS AND
MEANINGFUL ASSESSMENT OF THE
CONTRACTS. UH AND THE DOLLARS
ARE BEING SPENT TO WORK. THANK
YOU. AGAIN. 30 SECONDS, FOLKS.
HØI GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ANGIE MINETTI,
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE, SPEAKING ON
ISSUE TWO WANTED TO OFFER
COMMENT. UM, WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE L A Ó ANALYSIS THAT STATES
THAT THE STATE CAN CLOSE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE PRISON SAVING IN
A BILLION DOLLARS. UM WE
RELEASED A REPORT DETAILING HOW
THE SAVINGS CAN BE REDIRECTED
TOWARD, UM, SHARED SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT WITH THE COMMITTEE
NOW, SIX YEARS LATER, AS WE'VE
GOT, UH ONLY TWO PRISONS CLOSED
SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE STATE
TO CONTINUE. PRIORITIZE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS MICAH. DOCTOR I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE A.
èC LU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF A èC LU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND IN
COALITION WITH CURB TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO FOLLOW THE LAOS
RECOMMENDATION AND DIRECT èC Dð
èC R TO CLOSE AT LEAST FIVE
MORE STATE PRISONS. AS YOU'VE
HEARD, THIS WOULD SAVE THE STATE
NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS TO
SPEND ON OTHER CRITICAL
COMMUNITY SAFETY NEEDS LIKE
INDIGENT DEFENSE, COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS AND THOSE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GOING BACK IS THE
YELLOW BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. UH, WE SUPPORT THE
CHAIR'S GOAL OF A 15% CUT IN èC
Dð èC R AS YOU SAID BUDGETS ARE
NOT ABOUT SILOS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT INVESTMENTS IN HEALTH,
EDUCATION, WELFARE AND OTHERS.
WE NEED TO CLOSE FIVE PRISONS.
THAT'S A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
IN SUSTAINED SAVINGS WE CAN WITH
FEWER PRISONS AND FEWER
PRISONERS, AS THE SECRETARY
REQUESTED. WE CAN REFURBISH
CLASSROOMS. WE CAN DEVELOP
REHABILITATE PROGRAMMING WITHIN
THE WALLS OF FEWER PRISONS AND
STILL SAVE MONEY THAT WE CAN
INVEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES BEING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HØI COURTNEY
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN. PRISONERS
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PUSH FOR AT
LEAST FIVE ADDITIONAL PRISON
CLOSURES BEEN MONITORING THESE
CONVERSATIONS FOR OVER 15 YEARS,
AND IT IS SUCH A FAMILIAR
FEELING OF FRUSTRATION TO LISTEN
TO èC Dð èC R TRY TO JUSTIFY
THEIR CURRENT BUDGET AND EVEN
MORE MONEY WHEN WE KNOW THAT
EVERY ADDITIONAL DOLLAR GOING IN
THAT DIRECTION IN THIS FISCAL
CLIMATE IS GOING AWAY FROM
CLASSROOMS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THE ENVIRONMENT. UM AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARDS
TREATING INCARCERATED PEOPLE
LIKE HUMAN BEINGS, WHICH I FULLY
SUPPORT WITHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MODEL, BECOMING AN EXCUSE FOR
MORE AND MORE AND MORE FUNDING.
THANK YOU. HØI. MY NAME IS
ALICIA MONTERO. I'M WITH CURB.
UM UM I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR THE REALITY BASED
TRAINING FACILITY BEING PUT IN
PLACE JUST 35 MILES AWAY FROM
THE CURRENT REALITY BASED
TRAINING FACILITY THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING UTILIZED IN GALT
, CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY IN THE
MIDST OF ONE OF THE STATE'S
WORST DEFICITS EVER. WE NEED TO
CLOSE FIVE PRISON IS NOT OPEN,
ONE THAT HAS BEEN CLOSED FOR
YEARS. THERE'S NÓ JUSTIFICATION
TAKES AWAY FROM AN ALREADY
DWINDLING RESOURCES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. KENNETH HARTMAN
TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON WORK
GROUP REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. WE AGREE THAT 15,000 EXTRA
BEDS IS WAY TOO MANY, AND WE
ALSO ISSUE NUMBER THREE. WE
THINK OPENING UP AN OLD PRISON
TO DO REALITY BASED TRAINING
MAKES NÓ SENSE WHEN THERE'S NOW
A BUNCH OF EMPTY FACILITIES THAT
COULD DO IT. THANK YOU. NATASHA
MINSK. SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
CLOSED PRISONS FUND VICTIM
SERVICES FUND PUBLIC DEFENSE.
THANK YOU. HELLO JEAN VASQUEZ ON
BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
JUSTICE. I'M ALSO A SURVIVOR FOR
25 YEARS INSIDE INCARCERATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, AND I WOULD
SAY THAT THE INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE DOES NOT HELP. I
OPENED UP SLINGS VALLEY IN 96 S¼
F 98 BOTH BRAND NEW FACILITIES
AND DID NOTHING WHATSOEVER TO
HELP IN MY HEALING JOURNEY. SO
WE TALK ABOUT BUDGET CUTS. WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO TALK ABOUT
NOT JUST NOT INVESTING IN MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT ALSO
DISMANTLING A LOT OF THE MORE
PRESIDENTS THAT L A RECOMMENDED
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE. MY NAME
IS KERRY ARZATE. I'M WITH PRISON
FROM THE INSIDE OUT. WE WORK ON
THE INSIDE OF PRISONS AND ALSO
ON THE OUTSIDE. UM I'M ONE IN 41
OF FOUR OF EVERY WOMEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I STAND HERE
TODAY, UM, TO LET YOU KNOW WHAT
THE PRISON POPULATION DECREASING
AND THE BUDGET INCREASING THE
BUT THE VOTING PUBLIC IS CLOSELY
WATCHING HOW WE RESPOND TO THIS
BUDGET DEFICIT. WE CAN'T ALLOW,
UM, WE CAN'T AFFORD AFFORD TO
OVERLOOK AND UM, THE BUDGET
INCREASE TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS KELLY
WALTERS. I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN. I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET CUTS TO TRANS METRO, A
LIFELINE CONNECTING VULNERABLE
FAMILIES WITH THEIR INCARCERATED
LOVED ONES, CUTTING THIS ALREADY
UNDERFUNDED PROGRAM NOT ONLY
JEOPARDIZES ITS VITAL MISSION
BUT ALSO EXACERBATES THE
HEARTBREAKING REALITY OF
FAMILIES TORN APART. THE
COMMITTEE FAILS TO RECOGNIZE THE
IN THE CRUELTY OF FURTHER
ISOLATING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FROM THEIR LOVED ONE
I. I BEG YOU TO APPEAL TO REASON
RESEARCH. EQUIVOCALLY SHOWS THAT
THE FRAGMENTATION CORRELATES
WITH SOARING RECIDIVISM RATES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HØI. MY
NAME IS BERNICE SING ROGERS. I
AM A WIFE TO AN INMATE AT
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON. UM
IN THE LAST 10 YEARS. THE STATE
BUDGET DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT
REHABILITATION EXPENSES SUCH AS
PRISONER EDUCATION AND
ACTIVITIES HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR
ONLY 3% I THINK IT'S CRUCIAL TO
INVEST IN REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS FOR LEVEL THREE AND
FOUR INMATES. UM I ALSO AGREE
WITH CORRECTIONAL OFFICE. I MEAN
, I DON'T AGREE WITH RACES WHEN
I FEEL LIKE èC Ó S¼ NEED MORE
TRAINING. UM, BEING MORE
EMPATHETIC AND TO HELP WITH THE
REHABILITATION PROCESS. THANK
YOU. UM I. I DO JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING THAT I
STATED EARLIER AND I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A $15
MILLION BASELINE ADMINISTRATIVE
CUT FOR èC Dð èC R, WHICH
REPRESENTS 0.1% OF THEIR BUDGET,
A 1% CUT WOULD EQUATE TO 100 AND
$50 MILLION AND A 10% CUT WOULD
EQUATE TO 1.5 BILLION. THEIR
ENTIRE BUDGET IS ROUGHLY 15
BILLION, SO I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AGAIN. WE ARE LOOKING
FOR OPTIONS TO CUT ROUGHLY 15.
PER CENT AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND, UM, SEE
HOW WE CAN GO ABOUT THIS. UM WE
HAVE A HUGE DEFICIT AT 60
BILLION ESTIMATED ROUGHLY
DEBATABLE DEPENDING ON WHO YOU
ASK. SO UH, I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY. WE'VE HEARD, UH
FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC, UM,
MEMBERS THAT ARE IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT, UH, WE
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB-COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED.